GOOD AND WELCOME TO OUR
COMMUNICATION AND CONVEYANCE
COMMITTEE HEARING WEDNESDAY
APRIL SIX TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WE
ARE GOING TO ASK ASK THE
SERGEANTS TO CALL IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND WE DO LOOK LIKE WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO SHOULD WE JUST
DO THE ROLE RIGHT NOW. THIS IS
FOR QUORUM QUIRK-SILVA. KIRKUS
QUIRK-SILVA HI QUIRK-SILVA
PRESENT. PATTERSON PATTERSON
PRESIDENT BOERNER HORVATH MIA
BONTA YEAH BONTA PRESENT SAID
ABOUT THIS DAVIES DAVIS PRESENT
A LOT OF AB CM. HOLDEN LOW LOW
PRESENT MAIENSCHEIN RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ PRESENT VALLADARES
ADORES PRESENT DOCTOR WEBER DR
OUR PRESENT. EVERYBODY DIFFICULT
JUST TO GIVE A CONTEXT SOME OF
US ARE RUNNING BACK AND FORTH
FROM THE SWING SPACE TO HEAR
SOMETIMES ABOUT THIS IS MY
FOURTH TRIP TODAY SO I WASN'T
SURE IF I WAS VOTING OR WHERE I
WAS BUT I'M HERE NOW ALL RIGHT
WE WILL BE TAKING A PHONE LINE
WITNESS TESTIMONY AND WITH THAT
TO THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE. FIVE
SEVEN AGAIN. 877-692-8957 AND
WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF A DIFFERENT AGENDA TODAY.
WE WILL BE HEARING ONE BILL
AFTER WE HEAR THAT BILL THEN WE
WILL BE MOVING INTO A HEARING
FOR. AND WITH THAT WE ALSO HAVE
TWO BILLS THAT ARE ON PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY FILE ITEM
AB FILE ITEM ONE AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO MALEN. FILE ITEM
THREE AB TWENTY NINE ZERO SIX
PATTERSON AND WE WOULD LIKE.
CONSENT AND MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU CALL THE ROLL. FOR AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY TWO IT'S A DO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
QUIRK-SILVA HI QUIRK-SILVA HI
PATTERSON PATTERSON HI
BOERNER HORVATH MIA BONTA MIA
BONTA I SAID THIS. DAVIES DAVIES
I EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN LOW LOW
TIME MANAGE MAIENSCHEIN
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I
VALLADARES VALADARES HI DOCTOR
WEBER. DR WEBER I AND FOR AB.
TWENTY NINE ZERO SIX THAT IS A
DO PASS. TO THE FLOOR
QUIRK-SILVA HI QUIRK-SILVA I
PATTERSON PATTERSON I
BOERNER HORVATH MIA BONTA
FEDERAL BONTA I CERVANTES DAVIES
. THEY WITH AYE EDUARDO GARCIA
HOLDEN LOW. LOW I'M MAIENSCHEIN
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I
VALLADARES MOTORS AND DR WEBBER
. DR RHEIN. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO OUR ONE ITEM ON OUR
AGENDA AND WE WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS UP. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY THREE WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH A DIGITAL EQUITY BILL
OF RIGHTS WOULD MAKE. MAKE IT A
POP THE POLICY THE STATE FOR
BROADBAND TO BE SUFFICIENT
RELIABLE AFFORDABLE AND
UBIQUITOUS EVERYWHERE. IT WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
ADOPT RULES THAT FACILITATE
EQUAL ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INTERNET SERVICE. CUPBOARD
NINETEEN HIGHLIGHTED HOW WIDE
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE IS IN
CALIFORNIA HOW CRUCIAL BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS BECOME TO
MODERN LIFE. CLICK AGENCIES AND
SERVICES REQUIRED A STRONG
INTERNET CONNECTION TO ACCESS
THEM. WE SAW WORKING FAMILIES.
STRUGGLE IN BOTH URBAN AND RURAL
COUNTIES WITH HAVING THEIR
CHILDREN LEARN FROM ZOOM BECAUSE
OF A LACK OF AFFORDABLE AND
RELIABLE INTERNET SERVICE. IT IS
CLEAR THAT ACCESS TO RELIABLE
AND AFFORDABLE HIGH SPEED
INTERNET IS BECOMING A NECESSITY
IN TODAY'S DAY AND AGE. AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE WILL
MAKE BROADBAND MORE AFFORDABLE
AND RELIABLE BY FIRST
ESTABLISHING THE POLICY OF THE
STATE TO ENSURE DIGITAL EQUITY
FOR ALL RESIDENTS OF THE STATE.
SECOND TO DECLARE THAT ALL
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE HAVE A
RIGHT TO BROADBAND THAT IS
SUFFICIENT RELIABLE AFFORDABLE
AND UBIQUITOUS. AND THIRD
REQUIRING THE CPUC TO ADOPT
RULES TO FACILITATE EQUAL ACCESS
TO BROADBAND AND INTERNET
SERVICE AND ACCOUNT FOR
TECHNICAL AND ECONOMIC
FEASIBILITY PRESENTED PRESENTED
BY EQUAL ACCESS. IT IS CLEAR THE
BROADBAND TECHNOLOGIES AND
SERVICES ARE THE DEFINING TRAIT
OF THE DIGITAL AGE WHILE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SUPPORTED
PROJECTS THAT ARE CRITICAL TO
BRIDGING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE THE
STATE NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT
BEYOND THESE INVESTMENTS
CALIFORNIANS DO HAVE RELIABLE.
IS A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY CIVIL
RIGHT AND SHOULD BE TREATED AS
SUCH HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ARE SENATOR RICHARD
POLANCO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY FUND AND JAN
GOING ONTO STUDENT TRUSTEE FOR
THE LOS RIOS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. WELCOME MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE WITH YOU-
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
FUND AS WELL AS THE DIGITAL
EQUITY COALITION WE ARE HERE TO
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE A BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY FUND IS A
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATION. IT
IS DEDICATED TO CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IN OUR RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES. WE ARE HERE
TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE- THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS HAVE A
RIGHT TO BROADBAND IN VARIOUS
FORMS. AND FUNCTIONS AND TO
ENSURE DIGITAL EQUITY FOR ALL
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE. THE
ANALYSIS- BY COMMITTEE STAFF
POINTS OUT THAT THE FCC WILL
ADOPT THEIR RULES ON HOW TO
PREVENT AND ELIMINATE DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION. THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL AMERICANS HAVE EQUAL
ACCESS TO BROADBAND INTERNET WE
APPLAUD THOSE EFFORTS HOWEVER
THESE RULES AT THE FCC C. CAN BE
CHANGED WHEN A NEW FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION IS ESTABLISHED.
AND THEREFORE THIS BILL BECOMES
VERY IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIANS
THE MEASURE WILL ENSURE. THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE PROVIDED EXTRA
PROTECTION BY REQUIRING THE P.
YOU SEE. TO REVISE ITS COMPLAINT
PROCESSRELATING TO. DIGITAL
DISCRIMINATION. IT WILL REQUIRE
THE CPUC TO ADOPT RULES THAT
WILL PROMOTE EQUAL ACCESS TO
ROBUST. BROADBAND INTERNET
SERVICE BY PROHIBITING
DEPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION. THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE THIS BODY
HAS A HISTORY OF STEPPING UP TO
ENSURE THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIANS THEY DID IT WITH
THE JESS UNRUH ACT THEY'VE DONE
IT WITH THE RALPH. CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT AND THE RECENTLY DID WITH
THE CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT. THIS PARTICULAR PANDEMIC
ILLUMINATED. THE DISPARITIES
THAT EXIST IN OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES BOTH IN RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES. WE MUST NOT
LOSE SIGHT OF THE FACT THAT IN
THE COUNTY IN WHICH I LIVE.
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT THREE
MILLION. L. A. COUNTY RESIDENTS
CAN ONLY ACCESS. USING
SMARTPHONES ONE POINT TWO
MILLION UP L. A. COUNTY
RESIDENTS DO NOT HAVE ANY WAY TO
ACCESS THE INTERNET ACCORDING TO
THE SURVEY CONDUCTED BY THE
BERKELEY INSTITUTE OF GOVERNMENT
STUDIES. BANISHED THE ASSEMBLY
WEB BASED US OF A THE AUTHOR.
STATES BROADBAND IS THE IS
ESSENTIAL FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
DIGITAL EQUITY IS THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY ISSUE ON BEHALF OF
THE EMERGING ECHNOLOGY FUND THE
FORTY THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
PETITION SIGNERS WHO WHOEVER
ASKS THAT YOU CONTINUE THE
LEGACY TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL. NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY CENTER
FOR ONE GIRL GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS JUNGLE NOT
I'LL EVEN THAT MY TITLE WAS
STATED EARLIER TODAY I'M COMING
TO YOU AS A STUDENT FROM
SACRAMENTO CITY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FROM AT THE LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT WHICH
SERVES ANY ANYWHERE BETWEEN
750-008-0000 STUDENTS AMONGST
FOR COLLEGES I CURRENTLY AM ONE
OF THOSE STUDENTS AND LAST YEAR
I WAS A STUDENT FELLOW WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGING
TECHNOLOGY FIRMWARE SEVERAL MY
PEERS AND I LED A STUDENT
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. I SUPPORT ABC TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY THREE BECAUSE
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF AND MANY
OTHERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS
BROADBAND SERVICES EQUALLY AND
EQUITABLY WE'VE BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE THROUGHOUT
THE TIME IN THE KOBE PANDEMIC WE
ARE HEADING INTO OUR THIRD YEAR
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF HAVE BEEN
SEVERELY IMPACTED BY THIS AND
THEREFORE IN IN. CABLE TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS THE CLOSING OF THE
DIVOT DIGITAL DIVIDE I ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL WITH COULD
TRANSITION TO AN ONLINE LEARNING
BECAME A PLOT THAT CAME A
PLETHORA STUDENTS HER FIRST BUT
THEIR EDUCATION ON HOLD STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF I'M HEADING INTO MY
THIRD YEAR OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO
WITHOUT INTERNET RESOURCES
EXPRESSLY GIVEN THAT WE ARE IN
THE COPA PANDEMIC THE THIRTY
YEAR MAY I EMPHASIZE. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE CTF FOUND AT
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION
CALIFORNIANS DID NOT HAVE
INTERNET ACCESS FROM HOME AND
FIVE POINT NINE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS DID NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO A COMPUTER OR TABLET IMAGINE
THAT BEING THE CASE FOR ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN
CALIFORNIA CAN BE COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND I'M ONE OF THOSE
CALIFORNIA CAN COLLEGE STUDENTS.
ANOTHER REPORT FROM THE MONTH OF
THE PANDEMIC FOUND THAT WE WANT
ONE HUNDRED THAT. CALIFORNIA CAN
YOU STILL LIKE INTERNET. A I'M
ONE OF THOSE TEAMS AS WELL.
CALIFORNIA CANNOT RISK. A JOB.
OF STUDENTS AND THE WORK. AND
FUTURE WORKFORCE OVER BROADBAND
INEQUITIES. CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN
A BOLD ACTION TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND BECOME A
LEADER. AND AMONGST THE NATIONAL
LEVEL AND DIGITAL EQUITY BUT
THEY'RE STILL YET A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE. WE CAN CELEBRATE THE
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE WHILE
REMAINING REALISTIC ABOUT WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY STUDENT. AND EVERY
RESIDENT HAS ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE INTERNET WE ALSO NEED
PERMIT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
CONNECTS ALL STUDENTS. TO THE
DIGITAL CLUSTER MANAGERS THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN CONNECT TO
THE DIGITAL ECONOMY. VOTE YES
FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU. Q. WE ALSO HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WITNESS WE WOULD
INVITE BERNIE OROZCO WITH C. C.
T. H. PLEASE APPROACH THE
WITNESS TABLE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BERNIER OSCAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE ASSOCIATION WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE NOT
THAT WERE OPPOSED TO DIGITAL
EQUITY WE TOTALLY SUPPORT DID
YOU EQUITY WE'RE WE'RE OPPOSED
TO THE APPROACH THAT THIS BILL
TAKES SO THERE'S TWO PARTS TO
THIS BILL SO FIRST IT
ESTABLISHES A RIGHT FOR EVERY
CALIFORNIAN TO HAVE BROADBAND
ACCESS AND IS THAT RIGHT THAT
SETS A LITIGIOUS FRAMEWORK FOR
SUING SOMEONE EVERY EVERY EVERY
LAW CENTER PARK THAT YOU
MENTIONED. CALIFORNIANS HAVE
SUED BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN VIOLATED SO
SOMEBODY'S GONNA GET SUED
ESTABLISHED IN THIS RIGHT NOT
FROM IT BUT THAT'S A
JURISDICTION OF JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CELL BUT THAT IS OFF
TO THE SIDE THE SECOND ISSUE OF
THIS BILL IS THE DUPLICATE
DUPLICATIVE PROCESS THAT THE P.
YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENED
ESTABLISHING SOME NEW RULES AND
REGULATIONS FOR BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT. WITH THE GOAL OF
LOOKING AT WHY OUR COMMUNITIES-
MISSED IN BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT
OR MISTER BROADBAND SERVICE AS A
REDLINING IF YOU WILL- THE FCC
HAS JUST OPENED A NEW PROCEEDING
ON REDLINING ISSUE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHY DO CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES LACK BROADBAND
ACCESS OR WHY DO CERTAIN
CONSTITUENCIES LACK ACCESS TO
BROADBAND FROM AN ADOPTION
STANDPOINT BUT THE PC HAS HAD A
TWO YEAR PRECEDING AND THE
MAKING OF LOOKING AT THESE VERY
SAME QUESTIONS. SO THIS PROPOSAL
IS KIND OF JUMPING THE GUN OF
THAT RESULTS FROM THOSE TWO
STUDIES I THINK IT'S A WORTHY
DISCUSSION TO HAVE THOUGH
BECAUSE WE DO WONDER WHY IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THIRTEEN
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS ACCORDING TO
THE PC FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS LACK
BROADBAND SERVICE AT A SPEED OF
TWENTY FIVE AND THREE. THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE FOR THE HOUSEHOLD I
THINK COMPLEMENT TO THE CABLE
AND TELCO INDUSTRY FOR REACHING
296% OF HOUSEHOLDS IN CALIFORNIA
TO HAVE BROADBAND. BUT YET
THEY'RE STILL ONE POINT NINE
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO BROADBAND WHO DON'T
SIGN UP FOR THAT SERVICE STATE
THE H. THEY DON'T ADOPT. THAT
BROADBAND SERVICE SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT DIGITAL ACTIVE EQUITY.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IT FROM THAT
LAND SO LASHER SIX BILLION
DOLLARS WAS APPROPRIATED FOR
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEGISLATURE
DID NOT WEIGH IN ON HOW THAT
SHOULD GO IT WAS TO UN SERVED
AREAS OR AREAS FOR COMPETITION.
I WOULD CHALLENGE THAT THAT WAS
NOT THE BEST DIGITAL EQUITY PLAN
TO PUT FORWARD YOU DIDN'T PUT
YOUR STAMP ON IT I THINK YOU
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE. WE HAVE
SOME FUNDS ARE GONNA BE COMING
IN FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS ON TOP OF
THE ONES THAT WE RECEIVED.
CALIFORNIA CAN GAIN BOUT TWO
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS FROM
D. INVESTMENTS- THE I. I. J. A.
D. INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
JOBS ACT. SO ROUGHLY TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS INCOME IT.
SMARTLY THOUGH THIS TIME THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SAYS STATES
BEFORE YOU RECEIVE THAT MONEY
YOU MUST DEVELOP A DIGITAL
EQUITY PLAN. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA YOUR PROPOSAL ON
ESTABLISHING THAT WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THAT.
BEFORE ANY STEPS GO FORWARD WE
SHOULD HAVE A PLAN IN PLACE. TO
GET THOSE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS CONNECTED TO
GET THOSE ONE POINT NINE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS WHO COULD ACCESS
BROADBAND WHO DON'T THAT WE NEED
TO FIND OUT WHY THEY DON'T AND
LET'S GET THE- SHARE. ARE SOME-
RACE WE SHE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING THE DIGITAL EQUITY WE
JUST DON'T THINK THE BILL
ABSTRACTED HERE. DOES THAT WE
THINK THE BETTER WAYS FOR THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND GOVERNMENT TO
PARTNER LASHER WE CARRIED UP
LEGISLATION BY MR DALY- THAT
WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO SHARE WITH LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THE AVAILABILITY OF
LOW COST BROADBAND PLANS THAT WE
OFFER WHICH WE HAVE BEEN
OFFERING FOR OVER TEN YEARS WE
HAVE OFFERED LOW COST BROADBAND
PLANS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. BUT
THE HARD PART IN CTF NOTICES THE
HARD PART IS GETTING THOSE
FAMILIES AWARE OF THOSE THE
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE PROGRAMS
SO WE NEED TO WE NEED TO RESOLVE
THAT. AND THEN WE CARE
LEGISLATION TO GET PUBLIC
HOUSING- CONNECTED TO GET THE
COMPUTERS THERE DIGITAL LITERACY
LABS THAT WAS HELD IN ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. SO WE
WANT TO JOIN YOU AND WE WANT TO
MOVE FORWARD AND HELP CLOSE. OUT
BUT WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO
DIRECTLY JUST THE APPROACH.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO SUPPORT
WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM- YOU CAN. JOIN US AT THE
MICROPHONE. SUPPORT WITNESSES
ALL RIGHT NOT SEEN ANY WE WILL
INVITE UP OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
NOT SEEN ANY IN THE ROOM WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES- I'M NOT
SURE MODERATOR IF THEY'RE
SEPARATED BY SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION BUT WILL JUST OPEN
THE PHONE LINES. Q. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR OPINION ON
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. WE'LL GO FIRST TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I HAD NOT. IF THE ABOUT
BILL ALL. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE EIGHT EIGHT ABA NOT
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THAT LITTLE
HE BOB COMING UP ON THE FLOOR I
HAD NOT I CALL A MONTEREY WE
CAN'T HEAR HERE UNLESS I'M THE
ONLY ONE THAT CAN'T WORK SO WE.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY YES THAT'S A
DIFFERENT BILL THANK YOU
DIFFERENT DAY. OKAY MAX WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWO WILL. THIS IS THEIR
HOFFMAN I'M OF THE SCHOOL BOARD
TO SHOW. VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE
EDWARD- DR VOTE THANK YOU. HELP
LINE TWO THIRTY TWO. I'D SAY
THERE ARE THIRTY FOUR MARKS WITH
NEW START HOUSING AND WERE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU. HAVE
LINE ONE EIGHTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AB ONE WILLIAMS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
ORANGE COUNTY REGIONAL BROADBAND
COLLABORATIVE ASKING FOR YES
VOTE ON THE DIGITAL EQUITY BILL
OF RIGHTS THANK YOU. BLINDED TO
TWENTY NINE. STE GOOD AFTERNOON
ANGELINA SHARES ON BEHALF OF
VALLEY COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. AND
FINALLY WE HAVE LINE TO THIRTY
FIVE. I CLEARING. HERE IN A LINE
OKAY GREAT AND ANDREW LEWIS
NORTHWEST NEIGHBORHOOD WANT FULL
- SUPPORT FOR THE CURRENT BILL
THANK YOU. WITH THAT THIRD OFFER
LINES IN Q. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LINES OPEN. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO STATE OPPOSITION IN
MARIN AND THE PREVIOUS Q. ME
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. DO
YOU TURN ONLINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SO MY
MEMBER BONTA. I WANTED TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FORWARD
THIS BILL IT IS VERY MUCH A
COMPANION BILL FOR ME- FOR THE
DIGITAL EQUITY PLAN. THAT WE
WILL BE HOPEFULLY MOVING FORWARD
AS WELL AB I REALLY LOVE THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE ONLY STATES TO HAVE
ENUMERATED A RIGHT TO. EDUCATION
IN THE UNITED STATES AND I
BELIEVE THAT ESPECIALLY IN TIMES
OF TWENTY N. TYPE IN TIMES OF
PLENTY. THAT WE ACCOUNT FOR THE
FACT THAT. WE MIGHT NOT ALWAYS
BE THERE AND KNOWING THAT WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
ACCEPTABLE BROADBND FOR ALL. AS
ENUMERATED STATUTORY RATE IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS A RIGHT TO IT'S
AS IF WE ARE OFFERING. DIGNITY
REQUIRING DIGNITY AND DIGITAL
ACCESS SO I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE BRINGING FOR THIS
BILL AND I KNOW THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS THE OTHER ISSUES. WITHIN
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. REMEMBER LOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MANAGER-
LIKE TO ECHO MY COMMENTS AS WELL
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE ACCESSIBILITY
FOR ALL DISTRICT THE DISTRICT I
WORK FOR AS IN SILICON VALLEY
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ACCESSIBILITY THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
IN THROUGH THE CHAIR IF I MIGHT
JUST ASK A CLARIFYING QUESTION
WITH RESPECT TO THE TESTIMONY
YOU HEARD WITH RESPECT TO THIS
BILL AND- AS A AS A RIGHT- SIR.
THEN IF THE HAD THE- RESIDENT
WHO DESIRED TO- TO THE STATE IS
THAT IS THAT HOW YOU WOULD FOR
SEE THIS TO BE FUNCTION KEYS
HELP CLICK CLARIFY. WHAT THIS
WOULD MEAN THEN THAT WITH
RESPECT TO THE TEETH IN THE
MECHANISMS THAT WE WOULD HELP
IMPLEMENT TO ENSURE THAT TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY OFTENTIMES AS WE
ALL SHARE HERE WE PASS.
LEGISLATION BUT THE OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY SEEMS TO GET
AWAY FROM US AND I'M WE'RE
REALLY. CLOSE TACKLING IT WERE
TURNED OUT SO PERHAPS YOU CAN
HELP IN LINE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS IT. I THINK
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT THE
BILL DOESN'T JUST SAY YOU WON'T
HAVE AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO
BROADBAND. IT SAYS SPECIFICALLY
TO THE EXTENT TECHNICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE. SO IF THE
CABLE COMPANY SAYS IT
TECHNICALLY TECHNICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY IT CANNOT BE DONE.
THEY CAN SHOW THAT. BUT OTHER
THAN THAT WE JUST HAD THE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
INVESTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO
THAT WE COULD PROVIDE THIS AND
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER THIS
SHOULD BE A RIGHT FOR EVERY
CHILD GOING TO SCHOOL AND FOR
EVERY HOUSEHOLD THAT NEEDS TO
CONNECT THROUGH THE INTERNET-
ANOTHER THING THAT IF I MAY THAT
WAS. THAT WAS MENTIONED IS THE
FACT THAT TO. WHAT THE C. P. U.
C. WILL BE IS STUPID. IT'S GOING
TO BE COMPLEMENTARY BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE TO HAVE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY IF WE DON'T HAVE
THAT ACCOUNTABILITY. WHAT WE
PASS HERE WILL BE FOR NAUGHT.
WHITE HOUSE OF A BILL OF RIGHTS
IF YOU CANNOT ENFORCE IT WE HAVE
TO HAVE THE MECHANISM TO ENFORCE
IT AND THAT'S AN EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT PART OF IT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SEE NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR HANDS UP WILL
GO AHEAD AND ASK YOU TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR SORRY DID
YOU HAVE A- ONE MOVED BILL. OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND SECOND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU I THINK AS WAS STATED BY MY
COLLEAGUES EVERY CALIFORNIANS
SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
AFFORDABLE RELIABLE AND
SUFFICIENT INTERNET SERVICE AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOOKED. ALL RIGHT WILL
GO TO A VOTE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
QUIRK-SILVA HI QUIRK-SILVA HI
PATTERSON. PATTERSON NOT VOTING
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
HI MIA BONTA YEAH BONTA I SAID
ABOUT THIS SAID ABOUT THIS I
DAVIES DAVIES NOT VOTING EDUARDO
GARCIA HOLDEN HOLDEN I LOW. LOW
I MEANT MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ FIVE L.
DERIS BULGER NOT VOTING DR WEBER
DR WEBER ONLINE.
RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT AND IT
WILL BE REFERRED. NINE VOTES AND
IT WILL BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND WITH
THAT WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR
CONSENT ITEMS FOR THOSE WHO WERE
NOT HERE. THIS IS FOR CONSENT ON
AB TWENTY NINE OH SIX. AND
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO.
BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER HORVATH
I SAID ABOUT THIS SAID ABOUT
THIS I. HOLDEN HOLDEN I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN HI. A
CONSENT- ITEMS OR MOVE FORWARD
AND DO PASSED WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR CONSENT AND
THAT IS TWELVE. TWELVE ZERO. OUR
MEMBERS THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
TRICKY BUT I KNOW YOU ALL CAN DO
IT UP WE ARE GOING TO CLOSE THIS
A PART OF THE COMMITTEE- AND
GAVEL DOWN AND THEN WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO IS BEGAN OUR-
OVERSIGHT HEARING. WE'RE HOPING
YOU'LL STAY FOR A LITTLE BIT ALL
RIGHT WE ARE NOW CLOSING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR TODAY AND
WE WILL BEGIN OUR OVERSIGHT
PORTION OF THIS HEARING- THANK
YOU FOR ALL JOINING US THOSE IN
PERSON WE APPRECIATE IT- AND WE
WILL BE HEARING. FROM THE P. YOU
SEE ON LAST MILE BROADBAND. AND
ALSO THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND OR CAST SERVE AS
THOSE WHO ARE FOLLOWING ALL THIS
AND CALL IT CASS'S- BUT THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY. THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU DO ASK
YOUR QUESTIONS AND THAT YOU GET
YOUR QUESTIONS ANSWERED-
TOMORROW THE C. P. THE C. P. U.
C. IS SCHEDULED TO DROP THE
FINAL PROGRAM RULES FOR THE TWO
BILLION AND FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
WAS ALLOCATED. TO THE C. P. U.
C. AND LAST YEAR'S SB ONE FIFTY
SIX SO WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS THIS IS THE TIME TO
SPEAK UP- THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
DECISION- AS THE RULES- THAT ARE
ADOPTED. WHAT FOR APPLICANTS
WILL ALSO- THE THESE FEDERAL
FUNDS HAVE TIME LIMITS ON THEM
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET THESE APPLICATIONS IN AND
THEY GET OUT- AS A STATE IF WE
DO NOT GET THIS RIGHT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY LOSE OUT ON TIME
SENSITIVE. FUNDING RESULTING AND
UP WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
WHICH IS RETURNING FUNDS BACK TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND WE
DO NOT WANT TO SEND MONEY BACK
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO
WITH THAT I WANT TO. EXPLAIN
THAT I'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR FROM
THE BEGINNING AS THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE I PLANNED IT
EXERCISE. VERY VIGILANT
OVERSIGHT OF ALL THE AGENCIES
IMPLEMENT SB ONE FIFTY SIX.
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW WHAT WE DO
HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE AND AS
MANY OF THAT THAT MEMBERS HAVE
EXPRESSED WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE GETTING THIS RIGHT WITH
THE- THESE HUGE AMOUNT OF FUNDS
THAT ARE COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND FROM THE STATE.
ONE OF THE KEY FINDINGS IN THIS
REPORT- WHICH MIGHT SURPRISE
SOME OF US IS THAT EVERY MEMBER
HERE. IN EVERY MEMBER IN THIS
COMMITTEE BUT ALL OF OUR-
DISTRICTS HAVE UNSERVED
HOUSEHOLDS AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS DONUT
HOLES SOME DISTRICTS HAVE MORE
UNSERVED AREAS THAN OTHERS- BUT
FOR EXAMPLE IN ORANGE COUNTY YOU
WOULDN'T EXPECT. THIS BUT THERE
IS AN ESTIMATED THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS AND
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR THOUSAND UNSERVED
HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS THE STATE.
RURAL AND URBAN. IN THIS AFFECTS
ALL OF US AS WAS NOTED FROM THE
LAST PRESENTATION THAT IS HY WE
ARE TO HERE TODAY TO DO OUR PART
TO GET. THOSE UNSERVED
HOUSEHOLDS CONNECTED AND WE WANT
TO DO THIS AS SUFFICIENTLY AND
SMARTLY AS POSSIBLE AND I KNOW
THAT WE CAN AGREE ON THAT WITH
THAT I'M GOING TO ASK IF OUR
VICE CHAIR HAS ANY COMMENTS TO
MAKE. HE DOES NOT THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR PATTERSON AND NOW WE
WILL INNER DEUCE- FROM MR ROBERT
OSBORNE THE FROM THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION AND
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION- I
KNOW THAT THE DIRECTOR COULDN'T
MAKE IT TODAY BUT WELCOME AND
WE'RE GLAD YOU'RE HERE. YOU
SHOULD HAVE THIS HANDOUT- AT
YOUR HANDS IF YOU DON'T JUST
KIND OF RAISE YOUR HAND AND
WE'LL GET IT TOO. WELCOME THANK
YOU CHUCK QUIRK-SILVA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
CPC'S LAST MILE BROADBAND
FUNDING ACTIVITIES. MY NAME IS
ROBERT OSBORNE AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
DIVISION AT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. I'M HERE TO PROVIDE
AN AN INFORMATION ON THE STATUS
ON WHAT HAS CHANGED AND THOUGH I
DEFERRED TO OUR FIVE
COMMISSIONERS. ON WHO ARE
EVALUATING THE RECORD AND
VARIOUS POLICY CONSIDERATIONS.
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION IN
HERE AND IF WE RUN OUT OF TIME
WILL BE HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
MEMBERS LATER. THE BROADBAND
LEGISLATION PASSED LAST YEAR'S
SPECIFICALLY SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
AND SENATE BILL FOUR
DEMONSTRATED THE STATE SERIOUS
COMMITMENT TO CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. BY LEVERAGING
FEDERAL RECOVERY FUNDS TO
CONSTRUCT A STATE WIDE OPEN
ACCESS MIDDLE MILE NETWORK AND
FUND LAST MILE BROADBAND
NETWORKS. THE CPC RESPONDED
QUICKLY TO BEGIN IMPLEMENTING
THE HISTORIC LEGISLATION BY
SKIPPING THE VARIOUS FUNDING
PROGRAMS INTO TO CRITICAL.
RULEMAKINGS NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
SO WE'RE ON SLIDE TWO. SO THIS
SLIDE PROVIDES AN OVERVIEW OF
THE VARIOUS BROADBAND
INITIATIVES ENACTED WITH LAST
YEAR'S LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE IN
WHICH THE CPC IS INVOLVED. THE
BOX IN THE LEFT SUMMARIZES THE
CPC'S CONTRIBUTION TO THE THREE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR MIDDLE
MILE INITIATIVE LED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY. THE
GREEN BOX IN THE MIDDLE IS THE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS LAST MILE
INITIATIVE KNOWN AS THE FEDERAL
FUNDING ACCOUNT. A PROPOSED
DECISION ON THE RULES FOR THIS
ACCOUNT SCHEDULED FOR VOTE
TOMORROW BY THE COMMISSIONERS.
THE BOX ON THE RIGHT SUMMARIZES
THE OTHER SUPPORTING PROGRAMS TO
TRY WILL GO INTO INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND WOULD PROVIDE UBSIDIES FOR
THE BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT. OF BROADBAND
ADOPTION PUBLIC HOUSING AND
TRAVEL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NEXT
IS THE LOAN LOSS RESERVE ACCOUNT
WHICH PROVIDES UPFRONT CAPITAL
FOR DEBT SECURITIZATION. AND
FINALLY THE LOCAL AGENCY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES FUNDING
TO LOCAL AGENCIES FOR BROADBAND
PLANNING. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. NOW
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDING ACCOUNT TIMELINE
AND I APOLOGIZE THE TEXT IS
RATHER SMALL BUT I'LL JUST. GO
THROUGH SOME KEY UPDATES HERE SO
IS SHOWN IN THE TIMELINE IN
AUGUST THE CPC SCOPE TO THE
FEDERAL FUNDING ACCOUNT INTO THE
BROADBAND PROCEEDING. BETWEEN
OCTOBER AND DECEMBER THE CPC
DRAFTED THE PROPOSED PROGRAM
RULES. IN JANUARY THIS YEAR THE
US TREASURY RELEASED THEIR FINAL
RULE ON THE FEDERAL FUNDING. AND
TOMORROW AS I SAID THE CBC'S
SCHEDULED TO VOTE ON THE
PROPOSED DECISION ON PROGRAM
RULES. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE LEGISLATIVE
BROADBAND PACKAGE REMOVED A
NUMBER OF LONG STANDING BARRIERS
TO DEPLOYING BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR UNSERVED
AREAS. THE TOTAL FUNDING IS
THREE TIMES MORE THAN THE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
APPROPRIATED BY AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE. THE FUNDS ARE NOT LIMITED
BY COORDINATION OR DISTRIBUTION
BY FEDERAL AGENCIES SUCH AS THE
CONNECT AMERICA FUND- THE RURAL
DIGITAL OPPORTUNITY FUND. ON THE
PACKAGE MODERNIZE PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY BY INCREASING THE
SPEED FOR WHAT'S DETERMINED AS
UNSERVED. FROM SIX ONE TO TWENTY
FIVE THREE AND THE TWENTY FIVE
THREE AS WIRELINE ELIGIBILITY.
THAT IS CONSIDERED RELIABLE. SO
IT IN ADDITION THERE'S NO- RIGHT
OF FIRST REFUSAL TO LET DELAYS-
IT ALSO ALLOWS ENHANCEMENTS TO
THE OBJECTION PROCESS WHICH HAS
HISTORICALLY CAUSED DELAYS IN
EVALUATING APPLICATIONS.
APPROXIMATELY NINETEEN PARTIES
FILED COMMENTS REPRESENTING A
WIDE RANGE OF INTERESTS
INCLUDING PUBLIC ENTITIES
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS THE
CALIFORNIA TRIBE IN A RANGE OF
PUBLIC INTEREST GROUPS RATEPAYER
ADVOCATES AND NONPROFITS. I WILL
GO NOW INTO SOME OF THE PROPOSED
RULES AND REVISIONS IN MORE
DETAIL NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SB ONE
FIFTY SIX TASK THE CPC WITH
DIVIDING TWO BILLION BETWEEN AND
AMONG URBAN COUNTIES AND RURAL
COUNTIES SO ONE BILLION TO URBAN
COUNTIES AND ONE BILLION TO
RURAL COUNTIES. THE ALLOCATION
AND STATUTES STATES THAT EACH
COUNTY RECEIVES A BASE AMOUNT OF
FIVE MILLION WITH THE REMAINING
FUNDS APPORTIONED BY THE NUMBER
OF HOUSEHOLDS SERVED AT A
HUNDRED MEGABITS PER SECOND
BASED ONHISTORICAL AND FIXED IN
TIME AT THE END OF THE YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT DATA. SO
THE CPC MUST MAKE A
DETERMINATION ABOUT WHAT
QUALIFIES AS URBAN OR RURAL IN
THE STATUTE. THE PROPOSED
DECISION ADOPTS THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORKS COMPARATIVE
ANALYSIS OF SEVEN METHODOLOGIES
IN THE RECORD. THOSE INCLUDE THE
CENSUS BUREAU THE US DEPARTMENT
OF AGRICULTURE THE OFFICE OF
MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET US HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THE PEW CHARITABLE TRUSTS AND
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA. AT A HIGH LEVEL
THE UTILITY FRONT REFORM
NETWORKS PROPOSAL BALANCES THE
TO SIGNIFICANT REALITIES FIRST.
RURAL AREAS HAVE HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION COSTS DUE TO MORE
RUGGED TERRAIN POLLS WITH
GREATER FAILURE RATES AND LOWER
POPULATION DENSITY. URBAN
COUNTIES BY CONTRAST HAVE A
HIGHER NUMBER OF UNSERVED
HOUSEHOLDS. AND A PROPOSED
DECISION DISCUSSES THE
METHODOLOGIES AND RATIONALE IN
MORE DETAIL. NOW I'LL SPEAK
ABOUT PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. THE PROPOSAL
PROPOSED DECISION DEFINES
ELIGIBLE AREAS AS THOSE THAT ARE
UNSERVED BY WIRELINE PROVIDER
THAT CAN RELIABLY PROVIDE TWENTY
FIVE MEGABITS PER SECOND%
DOWNLOAD THREE MEGABITS PER
SECOND UP OR GREATER- AND
WIRELINE PROVIDER EXCLUDES FIXED
AND MOBILE WIRELESS SERVICE A
RELIABLE EXCLUDES LEGACY DSL AN
OLDER CABLE NETWORKS AND THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE U. S.
TREASURY FINAL RULE. THE
PROPOSED DECISION ESTABLISHES
PRIORITY PROJECT AREAS AS LARGE
PORTIONS OR ENTIRE COMMUNITIES
OFUNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS. THIS
WILL HELP MITIGATE PAST ISSUES
WITH APPLICANTS CHERRY PICKING
ONLY WEALTHY PARTS OF
COMMUNITIES. THE PROPOSED
DECISION ALLOWS APPLICANTS TO
PROPOSE THE ADDITION OR
SUBTRACTION OF OTHER HOUSEHOLDS
BASED ON A DEMONSTRATION OF
BROADBAND NEED CONSISTENT WITH
THE US TREASURY RULES. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. NOW COVERED THE
SLIDE- THE TITLE THE VALUATION
CRITERIA SO THE PROPOSED
DECISION SETS OUT SCORING
CRITERIA FOR APPLICATIONS
TOTALING A HUNDRED POINTS AS
DETAILED IN THE SLIDE. SO
BUILDING A PUBLIC NETWORK GETS
TWENTY POINTS SERVING A
COMMISSION IDENTIFIED PRIORITY
AREAS TWENTY POINTS PROVIDE
MATCHING FUNDS TEN POINTS
BUILDING FIBER INFRASTRUCTURE
TEN POINTS. PROVIDING LIFELINE
SERVICE TEN POINTS APPLICANT
EXPERIENCE TEN POINTS PROJECT
VIABILITY TEN POINTS AND
LEVERAGING STATE MIDDLE MILE
ETWORK IF REASONABLE TEN POINTS
. THE REVISED PROPOSED DECISION
ALSO REQUIRES THE COMMUNICATIONS
DIVISION TO INCLUDE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION SUCH AS THE NUMBER
OF LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS OR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY STATUS
IN DEVELOPING PRIORITY AREAS AND
ONE OF THAT'S INCLUDED IN THAT
LIST OF SCORING CRITERIA. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. AT A HIGH LEVEL
THE PROPOSED DECISION INCLUDES
TWO REQUIREMENTS BASED ON US
TREASURIES FINAL RULE. FIRST THE
PARTICIPATION IN THE FCC'S
AFFORDABLE CONNECTIVITY PROGRAM.
AND THAT ANY ADDITIONAL LOW COST
OPTION BE WITHOUT DATA CAPS AND
AT SUFFICIENT SPEEDS. THE
PROPOSED DECISION REQUIRES A LOW
COST OPTION FOR- FIFTY DOLLARS A
MONTH. SORRY FORTY DOLLARS A
MONTH FOR A FIFTY MEGABITS PER
SECOND DOWN AND FIFTY MEGABITS
PER SECOND UP WITH THE
FLEXIBILITY IF NEEDED BY AN
APPLICANT. IT OFFERS EXTRA
POINTS IF PARTICIPATING IN MY
FIND AND THAT AFFORDABLE PLANS
BE OFFERED FOR THE LIFE OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. PLAN PRICES CAN
BE LOWERED BUT CANNOT INCREASE
FOR TEN YEARS WITHOUT COMMISSION
APPROVAL. THERE'S A WAIVER
PROCESS- THE FOR CHANGED
CIRCUMSTANCES OR FOR A MODEL
SUCH AS SERVICE BASED
COMPETITION MODEL THAT MIGHT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED MORE
SPECIFICALLY- DOWN THE ROAD BUT
THIS WAIVER PROCESS THAT I'M
MENTIONING IS SOMETHING THAT.
HAS BEEN INCLUDED IN THE REVISED
PROPOSED DECISION NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. THE PROPOSED DECISION
OUTLINES THE PROCESS FOR
ENTITIES TO OBJECT TO A PROPOSED
PROJECT AREA IS ALREADY SERVED
FOR HAVING DEMONSTRATED
BROADBAND NEED THAT IS NOT
REFLECTED IN THE BROADBAND
MAPPING DATA. THE PROPOSED
DECISION REFORMS THE PROCESS
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS
CHALLENGE PROCESS WHICH CAUSED
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER. AND JUST TO
NOTE THAT THE US TREASURY'S
FINAL RULE ENCOURAGES FUNDING
PORTIONS OF CERTAIN AREAS IF
NEEDED FOR CONDIMENTS OF SCALE.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. THE PROPOSED
DECISION DELEGATES TO THE CPC
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION STAFF
THE AUTHORITY TO APPROVE
STRAIGHTFORWARD NON
CONTROVERSIAL APPLICATIONS THAT
MEET SPECIFIC CRITERIA. IN ORDER
TO EXPEDITIOUSLY GRANT FUNDS.
THE REQUIREMENTS WERE INFORMED
BY PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VENTS SERVICES FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM MINISTER
OVERVIEW THE TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
MINISTERIAL REVIEW AN
APPLICATION NEEDS TO MEET THE
PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
FIRST- CANNOT RECEIVE ANY VALID
OBJECTIONS OR COMPETING
APPLICATIONS. OF THE TOTAL
PROJECT VALUE MUST BE LESS THAN
TWENTY FIVE MILLION- IT CANNOT
REQUIRE ANY SEEK FOR REVIEW- THE
TOTAL COST PER HOUSEHOLD NEEDS
TO BE- BELOW THE NINE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS. A PER
HOUSEHOLD THRESHOLD. AND THERE
CAN'T BE ANY WAIVER OR OTHER-
OTHERWISE ANY DEVIATION FROM
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS. BACKSLIDE
PLEASE. SO THE REVISIONS THAT
WERE PUBLISHED YESTERDAY MAKE A
NUMBER OF CHANGES TO THE
PROPOSED DECISION IN RESPONSE TO
PARTY COMMENTS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THE PROPOSED DECISION IS
SCHEDULED FOR VOTE TOMORROW
SUMMARIZING THE REVISIONS SO ON
AFFORDABILITY THE REVISIONS DO
NOT CHANGETHE TENURE PRICE CAP
AND- THE FORTY DOLLAR LOW COST
PLAN. THESE CAN BE MODIFIED BY
WAIVERS I MENTIONED EARLIER THE
REVISIONS CLARIFY THE WAIVER
PROCESS AND ADDED LANGUAGE TO
SHOW POSSIBLE CRITERIA FOR
WAIVER INCLUDING INFLATION. WITH
RESPECT TO THE LETTER OF CREDIT
REQUIREMENTS THE PROVISIONS
REMOVED THE LETTER OF CREDIT
REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS. I'M PRIORITY AREAS-
THE- REVISED- PROPOSED DECISION
ADDS DISADVANTAGED IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AS A FACTOR FOR
PROJECTS SELECTION. AND FINALLY
ON THE OBJECTION- CHALLENGE
PROCESS THE REVISIONS CLARIFY
THE OBJECTION PROCESS TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS PROVIDER
CONCERNS WITH SUBMITTING
CONSUMERS CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION TO VERIFY THAT IN
AREAS ALREADY SERVED AND AT ITS
WORST- STREAMLINED THE
INFORMATION THAT'S TO BE FILED.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. IT'S NOT
GOING TO SWITCH TO THE LOCAL
AGENCY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. SO
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW KEY
DATES- IN SEPTEMBER THE CPC
ISSUED A STOP PROPOSAL WITH
PROGRAM ROLES RELEASED SOLICITED
COMMENTS AND REPLY COMMENTS IN
JANUARY THIS YEAR THE CPC
RELEASED A PROPOSED DECISION
SOLICITED COMMENTS AND REPLY
COMMENTS AND AT THE END OF
FEBRUARY THE CPC ADOPTED FINAL
PROGRAM ROLES. WE'RE NOW IN THE
PROCESS OF CONDUCTING OUTREACH
TO LOCAL AREAS AND- FOLLOWING
THAT WILL BE WORKING ON ISSUING
GRANTS UNDER THE LOCAL AGENCY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION SO NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO THE BROADBAND PACKAGE
TASK THE CBC WITH THE WARNING
FIFTY MILLION FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- TO PUBLIC ENTITIES
AND NONPROFITS TO PREPARE- TO
PROVIDE SERVICE IN THE COMMUNITY
SO A LOCAL AGENCY IN THIS IS
COME UP SEVERAL TIMES WHAT IS A
LOCAL AGENCY IT'S LISTED AND IN
THE DECISION SO. LOCAL AGENCY
CONSTITUTES A CITY A COUNTY
INCLUDING A COUNTY SERVICE AREA
COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT A
PUBLIC UTILITY DISTRICT
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT JOINT
POWERS A THIRTY. LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY- SOVEREIGN
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND
ELECTRICAL COOPERATIVE THE FUNDS
CAN COVER A RANGE OF COSTS TO
DEPLOY A LAST MILE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITTING NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS AND STRATEGIC PLANS
. CPC WILL BE HOLDING PUBLIC
WEBINARS TO PRESENT AND DISCUSS
THE PROJECT APPLICATION PROCESS
WITH ELIGIBLE ENTITIES- AND
WE'RE TARGETING THAT FOR ME.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. NEXT WE'RE
GONNA SWITCH TO THE LOAN LOSS
RESERVE AND HERE'S SOME KEY
MILESTONES JUST TO RECAP THE
LOAN LOSS RESERVE IS A FUND
INTENDED TO PROVIDE UPFRONT
CAPITAL TO SECURITIZED DEBT. FOR
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT SO IN
SEPTEMBER THE PC ISSUED AN
AMENDED SCOPING ROLLING TO
INCLUDE THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
PROGRAM IN MARCH THE PC ISSUED A
RULING REQUESTING COMMENT ON
LOAN LOSS RESERVE STRUCTURE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
FINANCING REPORTING A STEP
PROPOSALS PLANNED FOR AUGUST OF
THIS YEAR FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
WE'RE TARGETING THE FIRST
QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE
FOUR- BEGINNING TOWARD FUNDS.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. THE BRIEFLY
OUT SNAPSHOT OF THE LOAN LOSS
RESERVE- THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION- OVER THREE YEARS
COMMITTED FOR THE PROGRAM. AS I
SAID THE PURPOSE IS TO ASSIST
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND NONPROFIT
ENTITIES TO FINANCE AND BUILD
OUT THEIR OWN LAST MILE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE LAW MUST
RESERVE FUND WILL PROVIDE
COLLATERAL TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ENABLE BETTER BORROWING RATES
AND TERMS FOR BONDS ISSUED TO
DEPLOY BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO IN TERMS
OF NEXT STEPS COMMENTS OF THE
PROGRAM- WE'RE DUE MARCH FIRST
NO WE HAD OPENING COMMENTS
REGARDING QUESTIONS ON THE
PROGRAM DESIGN AND
IMPLEMENTATION WERE DUE LAST
FRIDAY. AND REPLY COMMENTS ARE
DUE APRIL TWENTY SECOND. WERE
AIMING TO ISSUE A STAFF PROPOSAL
FOR COMMENT BY AUGUST OF THIS
YEAR. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO
FINALLY THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
SERVICES FUND SO BRIEFLY ALL THE
CASF CALIFORNIANS ARE SENT
SERVICES FUND INFRASTRUCTURE
APPLICATIONS WERE ACTED ON
BEFORE THE END OF LAST YEAR. IN
JANUARY THE CPC DEVELOPED DRAFT
PROGRAM ROLES A PROPOSAL FOR
LEGACY CASF SUB ACCOUNTS AND SUB
ACCOUNT ALLOCATIONS ASSIGNING
RESOURCES TO PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPLEMENTATION. A MARCH
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
RULING PROPOSED RULE
MODIFICATIONS FOR PUBLIC HOUSING
ACCOUNT THE ADOPTION ACCOUNT AND
THE CONSORTIA COUNT. THE RULING
ALSO PROPOSED CASF SUB ACCOUNT
ALLOCATIONS FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
INVITED PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT
PROPOSAL FINAL ROLES AND
ALLOCATIONS WILL- BE ADOPTED BY
DECISION AS EARLYAS- JUNE AND
THOSE INCLUDE- THE ONES THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE FOR THE
SUB ACCOUNTS. THE PC PLAN STOOD
UP FINAL PROGRAM ROLES AND SUB
ACCOUNT ALLOCATIONS AND IN THE
BEGINNING SEPT IN APPLICATIONS
IN JULY. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO
JUST RUNNING THROUGH THE VERY
SUB ACCOUNTS OF THE PUBLIC
HOUSING ACCOUNT IMPLEMENTATION
WE REQUEST TO COMMENT ON HOW TO
IMPLEMENT CHANGES AND SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY SIX INCLUDING
EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OUTSIDE OF
PUBLICLY SUPPORTED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS AND JUST HER TO
RECAP SO IN IN THE PAST WE WERE
LIMITED TO PUBLICLY SUPPORTED
HOUSING AND NOW THIS DEFINITION
HAS- UNDER LEGISLATION HAS
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE MOBILE HOME
PARKS IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
. NEXT THE BROADBAND ADOPTION
PROGRAM REVISIONS INCLUDED
HIGHER MINISTERIAL REVIEW LIMITS
MORE REIMBURSABLE COSTS AND
INCREASED FLEXIBILITY FOR
APPLICANTS SEEKING REIMBURSEMENT
. ON THE BROADBAND CONSORTIUM
PROGRAM REVISIONS- PROPOSALS
INCLUDE EXPANDING CONSORTIUM
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ALLOW THEM
TO SSIST POTENTIAL APPLICANTS
FOR ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS CREATED
UNDER SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY SIX
. AND THEN- CASF ACCOUNT
APPROPRIATIONS SO ACROSS ALL THE
SUB ACCOUNTS THE PREPARATIONS
ARE BASED ON HISTORICAL DRAWS OF
THE FUNDS WITH THE JUDGMENTS TO
EXPAND ALLOCATIONS FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS FOR WHICH WE INCREASED
GRANT LIMITS. EXPANDING THE
SCOPE OF ELIGIBLE COSTS OFF
WHICH WE ANTICIPATE MORE
APPLICATIONS SUCH AS- THE PUBLIC
HOUSING ADOPTION CONSORTIUM. SO
I REALIZE IT'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT I WENT THROUGH
AND- THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
AND I AM AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU EXCELLENT-
HAND OUT AND INFORMATION IN AS
THE MEMBERS MIGHT AGREE THERE IS
QUITE A BIT TO TAKE CAN AND WE
APPRECIATE. YOUR HARD WORK- I
THINK I'M GONNA OPEN UP TO OUR
VICE CHAIR FIRST IF HE HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS NO AND
WITH THE OTHER MEMBERS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER YES
I APPRECIATE YOUR REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK THAT YOU REFER ON THE
SET UP HEARINGS TAKING US VERY
METHODICALLY THROUGH IT.
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND ONE OF
THE THINGS I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
IS NONE OF MY CITIES ARE TRYING
TO DO A PUBLIC AND YOU KNOW
BROADBAND RIGHT WE DON'T HAVE
THE CAPACITY THE CITIES DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY AND SO WHEN I
LOOK AT IT- I'M CONCERNED I'M
NOT CONCERNED I'D LIKE TO HEAR
AN EXPLANATION FOR HOW YOU
THINK- SOME OF OUR SERVICE
PROVIDERS WILL COME INTO
OCEANSIDE'S SPECIFICALLY THAT'S
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT- WITH
THE TEN YEAR PRICE FREEZE
ACTIVATE YOU CAUGHT A CAP. THE
CONFERENCE BUT WITH THE TAKING
OF THE TEN YEAR CAP JUST KNOWING
HOW TECHNOLOGY IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS HAVE ADVANCED IT SEEM AN
LOOKING AT INFLATION AND SOME
OTHER- ASPECTS IT SEEMS TENURE
SEEMS A VERY LONG TIME TO EXPECT
THAT ANYBODY WOULD FIND THAT
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE EVEN WITH
PUBLIC FUNDING TO PROVIDE THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT THAT I THINK I
NEED AN OCEANSIDE CAN YOU WALK
THROUGH YOUR LOGIC OF THE CAP
AND HOW TO HOW ARE YOU
ACCOUNTING. FOR ON THE INCREASE
GIVEN EITHER TECHNOLOGICAL
INCREASES OUR TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENTS OR INFLATION
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE WHEN
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW ONE ONE
HAVE ACCOUNTED FOR INFLATION IN
THE CAP OVER TEN YEARS IF YOU'RE
GONNA GO THAT LONG SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU GUYS GONNA DO
THAT SOME OF YOU CAN COMMENT ON
THAT PLEASE CERTAINLY FIRST I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO. EXPRESS THE
HOPE THAT THE INTEREST BY THE
MAJOR INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
IN THIS TOPIC IT MAY BE
DEMONSTRATE THEIR INTEREST IN
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAMS
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD- PROBABLY
THREE A THREE HEADED THE FIVE
MAJOR PROVIDERS THAT ACCOUNT
495% OF THE BRIBE AND SUBSTANCE
HAVE NOT HISTORICALLY
PARTICIPATED IN THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND OVER THE
PAST DECADE SETTLE I'M- THE CASE
TWELVE. THE MAJOR PROVIDERS-
SECOND OF ALL I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT- THE PC'S EXPERIENCE
WITH THE FEDERAL FUNDING
THROUGHOUT THE PAST TEN YEARS IS
THAT THE YIELD ON THE INVESTMENT
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY LOW BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF AFFORDABILITY AND
MIGHT SAY FORD ABILITY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE IS
NOT THE LOWING ARE YOU ABLE TO
CALL FOR THE. ATP CONTACT THE
PER PEOPLE WHO FALL OUT OF THAT
TWO HUNDRED POPULAR WHICH IS A
SIX PORTION THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WHO DON'T
QUALIFY FOR LIFE LINER FOR SNAP
SO THAT'S READ THE LOGIC BEHIND
HAVING AN AFFORDABLE PLAN THE
IDEA BEHIND HAVING THE TENURE IS
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO FIND A WAY
TO MAKE GOOD USE OF THE FEDERAL
MONEY IN THE INVESTMENT. REALLY
TRYING TO GET THE MOST BANG FOR
THE BUCK SO- THAT'S THE IDEA BUT
BASED ON FEEDBACK THAT WE GOT AS
AS YOU SORT OF ALLUDED TO WE
HAVE INTRODUCED THIS WAIVER
CAPABILITY AND WE HAVE WE HAVE
IN THE PAST UNDER CASF HAVE
PROVIDERS APPLY FOR A WAIVER FOR
THINGS SUCH AS A PRICE FOR A
PRICE CAP- OVER A PERIOD AND
CASF IT'S FOR TWO YEARS BUT
WE'REINCREASING THAT TO TEN SO
THERE ISN'T. AN ABILITY FOR
PROVIDERS TO COME IN AND SAY HEY
YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE SOMETHING
THAT WE'D LIKE TO PROPOSE IN
LIEU OF WHAT YOU HAVE IS A
REQUIREMENT. BUT WHEN I LOOK AT
THE OF. SORRY WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE AFFORDABILITY IF I COULD TO
THE CHAIR. WE LOOK AT THE FORT
ABILITY. THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SOMEBODY WHO'S AT 4100%
OF THE FIVE POVERTY LEVEL. AND
SOMEBODY LIKE MAYBE SOME OF MY
NEIGHBORS AN INFINITY. AND YOU
KNOW WE WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE
WHEN WE LOOK FOR THE MOST BANG
FOR THE BUCK. THAT WE USED TO
HAVE SOME. CRITERIA THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR THE AFFORDABILITY
PROGRAM TODAY MISS SAID THAT
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
AFFORDABILITY. THAT'S CORRECT
AFFORDABLE PLAN DOES NOT HAVE
ANY REQUIREMENTS- THE IDEAS
THAT. YOU WOULD HAVE A BASIC
PLAN THAT'S AVAILABLE TO ANYBODY
REGARDLESS OF INCOME LIMIT-
BASED ON THE- INVESTMENT THAT
WE'RE MAKING IN THE NETWORK
SWITCHES UP TO A 100% OF THE
NETWORK WERE ESSENTIALLY
PROVIDING. FREE NETWORKS TWO
CARRIERS. SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING
FOR GOING TO BE PROVIDING YOU
WITH THIS FREE NETWORK OBVIOUSLY
THERE ARE OPERATING COSTS BUT-
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SOME
BASIC. STANDARD PLAN THAT PEOPLE
CAN AVAIL THEMSELVES OF. THE
ONLY PROBLEM WITH THAT AS YOU
WERE JUST SAYING THAT YOU'RE
CONCERNED THAT THREE OF THE FIVE
HAVE NEVER APPLIED FOR CASH THE
FUNDING. AND IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'RE CREATING A PLAN WHERE
THOSE THREE OR FIVE. PROBABLY
WON'T EVER APPLY FOR THIS
BECAUSE IF I WERE RUNNING THESE
COMPANIES I WOULDN'T APPLY FOR
IT. IF I ADDED A YOU KNOW A TWO
YEAR. CAP MAKES SENSE BECAUSE
YOU YOU GENERALLY IN THE
INDUSTRY CAN PROJECT OUT WHAT
ARE YOUR COSTS FOR TWO YEARS.
REAPPLY READJUST- AND IF YOU
DON'T HAVE AN INCOME REQUIREMENT
ON IT. I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY
WOULD PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM SO IF YOU'RE OBJECTIVE
IS TO GET THEM TO PARTICIPATE.
IN THIS 95% THE NETWORK. AND IN
CITIES LIKE MINE WHERE YOU DON'T
HAVE A PUBLIC. OPTION DO YOU SEE
THE PROBLEM THAT I BASICALLY
THINK. PLACES WITH PUBLIC
OPTIONS WILL HAVE AN ADVANTAGE.
THE I. S. B. THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS WILL NOT BUILD OUT IN
OCEANSIDE. AND OCEANSIDE WILL BE
LEFT BEHIND AT OCEANSIDE IS
TYPICALLY BEEN LEFT BEHIND. SO I
HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
THIS IS CONSTRUCTED I REALLY
ENCOURAGE THE PC. TO GO BACK AND
LOOK AT. SETTING SOME SORT OF
INCOME AVAILABILITY AROUND THIS.
AND THINKING ABOUT CITIES THAT
DO NOT WILL NOT HAVE A PUBLIC
OPTION ON MY CITIES WILL EVER
HAVE A PUBLIC OPTION THAT'S NOT
ANYTHING TO DO- SO. REALLY THINK
ABOUT THAT AND MAYBE CONSIDER A
FIVE YEAR CAP. RATHER IT RATHER
THAN A TEN YEAR TENURE JUST
SEEMS LIKE. FAR TOO LONG IN THE
FUTURE AND THIS TOO MANY OPTION.
THIS TOO MUCH UNPREDICTABILITY A
TEN YEAR CAP. THAN  TWO YEAR
CAP. SO MAYBE YOU NEED TO
INCREASE OF FROM TWO I TOTALLY
GET THAT. BECAUSE YOU'RE GIVING
THEM YOU KNOW BASICALLY. PUBLIC
FUNDING YOU SHOULD HAVE THAT
PUBLIC BENEFITS I GET. I AGREE
WITH YOU ON THAT CALCULATION. I
THINK MAYBE YOUR NUMBERS OR
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OFF. AND
REALLY CONSIDER THE PSC. WE
CONSIDER. THE TIME FRAME. AND
ADDING AFFORDABILITY LIMIT.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE I THINK WHAT
YOU CAN'T SEE IS PEOPLE WHO
DON'T NEED THE FORD ABILITY.
WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT. AND
pPEOPLE WHO DO NEED THE
AFFORDABILITY LIKE IN OCEANSIDE
WON'T GET IT. AND THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT THE OBJECTIVE THAT
I THINK WE HAS THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE GIVEN- OR THAT I WOULD WANT
FOR MY CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ARE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I. BEFORE IT'S ANOTHER
TOPIC I DID WANT TO CONCUR WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- FROM THE SOUTH
BOERNER HORVATH I WANT TO SIT
AROUND WHERE BOERNER HORVATH.
COULD YOU GET OKAY
BOERNER HORVATH- I D. I TO HAVE
THAT FIRST I GUESS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS IS DOES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REQUIRE THAT
APPLICANTS BE OFFERED A LOW COST
COST PLAN TO EVERY HOUSEHOLD.
THE TREASURY FINAL ROLE- SAYS
THAT THERE SHOULD BE A LOW COST
PLAN DOESN'T SAY TO EVERY
HOUSEHOLD BUT IT DOES SAY THE
VAST TO BE OFFERED. BECAUSE MY
CONCERN- AND I'VE EXPRESSED THIS
BEFORE IT IS FOR SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT MAY BE. MOST
NEEDING THIS PROGRAM THEY MAY
NOT HAVE THE ACCESS TO GET THE
PROGRAM- OR INFORMATION AND THEN
FOR OTHERS WHO ARE- YOU KNOW
FOLLOWING THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THEY MAY IN FACT GET
THOSE- BUT I ALSO AGREE WITH THE
FIVE YEAR I MEAN IN THIS CLIMATE
THAT W ARE WITH INFLATION ALL
OF THESE THINGS THAT WE SEE AS
FAR AS PRICE CHANGE IN A TEN
YEAR PRO. AND I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
USING- YOU DID MAKE A CHANGE
FROM NOT USING FREEZE TO WHAT
YOU CHANGED IT TO A TO A CAP BUT
I MAY BE A FIVE YEAR REVIEW
WOULD BE SOMETHING I THINK COULD
BE A LITTLE BIT OF THE MIDDLE
GROUND THERE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER P.
I WANT TO JOIN WITH THE OTHER
MEMBERS WHO HAVE EXPRESSED THIS
KIND OF CONCERNED. ABOUT A TAPE
BUT LITTLE BIT OF A STEP FURTHER
I ACTUALLY THINK THAT IF SOME OF
THESE- GOVERNMENT ENTITIES. OUR
ATTEMPT WITH A TEN YEAR AND A
CAP THAT I THINK IT'S FORTY. I
THINK WE MAY END UP WITH- GOOD
INTENTIONS AND BANKRUPTCIES.
THIS IS REALLY A VERY SERIOUS
ISSUE AND WE HAVE BEEN HERE NOW
AT LEAST THE SECOND. TIME WE'VE
SAT AND TALKED ABOUT THIS AND
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT A- AT A
RATE. FREEZE CAP FOR TEN YEARS
THAT'S NUMBER ONE I MEAN NUMBER
TWO I CONCUR WITH THE CONCERN
THAT YOU ARE CREATING A TEMPLATE
WHICH IS A DISINCENTIVE TO THE
VERY PRIVATE SECTOR GROUPS THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ATTRACT. AND I
THINK THAT THE IF THIS IS AN
ARBITRARY NUMBER IT AT BOTH AT
THE RATE M. VIA THE TIME PERIOD-
I THINK THERE'S A GENERAL
CONSENSUS HERE THAT THIS IS A
THIS IS AN ONGOING CONCERN. AND
THIS IS THE SECOND HEARING I'VE
SAT THROUGH I DON'T SEE ANY FIX
TO THIS HOW MANY TIMES DO WE
HAVE TO TELL YOU TO PROBLEM.
WE'RE JUST HOPING MAYBE THERE
THERE COULD BE SOME GOING BACK
FOR RECONSIDERATION I KNOW THAT
THERE IS A VOTE TOMORROW AND WE-
WERE KIND OF IN. THIS SCENARIO
WHERE WE ARE WE HAVE THIS
URGENCY WE WANT TO MOVE FORWARD.
BUT WE ALSO DON'T WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD- IF WE'RE NOT CONFIDENT
ON SOME OF THE MEASURES. BUT I
UNDERSTAND THE CONFLICTING
MESSAGES THAT YOU. AND OTHERS
THAT ARE WORKING ON THIS ARE
GETTING AND WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
BE- YOU KNOW OVERBEARING WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO SAY WE'RE NOT.
WHERE WE HAVE SOME ISSUES WITH-
THE FORTY DOLLAR AND THE TEN
YEAR- BUT AGAIN I THINK WE'VE
EXPRESSED THAT SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO A QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS REGARDING. WELL I WAS
GONNA HAMMER HAMMER IT HOME
AGAIN I ACTUALLY THINK THAT THAT
THE OTHER CONCERN ISAROUND THE-
LONGER TERM INFRASTRUCTURE I IN
THIS WORLD UNLIKE OTHER. OTHER
AT UTILITIES IT'S CONSTANTLY
DEVELOPING RIGHT WE'VE LIVED IN
A VERY SHORT TIME. FROM GOING
FROM THREE G. TO FOUR G. TO FIVE
G. IN TERMS OF THE KIND OF RATE
OF SPEED THAT'S- THAT'S REQUIRED
OR AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE AND WHAT
I WOULD HATE TO SEE HAPPEN. IN
EVEN IN URBAN DISTRICTS LIKE
MINE- IN OAKLAND WHERE WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FOR- THAT
PRIVATE ENTITIES WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS TO BE ABLE
TO ACTUALLY INVEST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE IT TO. A TO
PROVIDED SO I DO SEE THAT THERE
IS KIND OF A LONGER TERM-
CONCERN IT IN TERMS OF ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE-
THROUGH A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP AS THIS IS INTENDED
TO BE. A TO BE ABLE TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
GRANT PROGRAM IF WE ARE- THAT.
NOT PROVIDING THE CAPACITY FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
WITHIN. A GIVEN THE LONG TIME
RANGE THAT WHERE ASSOCIATING
WITH THIS SO I WOULD. HOPE THAT
WE CONSIDER AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THEIR BE PARITY BETWEEN.
THIS PROGRAM- AND THAT THAT THE
OTHER PROGRAM THAT HAS A TWO
YEAR LIMITATION. THANK YOU I
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER PARTNER
HERE HORVATH I'LL GET IT TBH
TASHA. I OF ALL NAMES I AM
INTERESTED. TO MAKE SOME FURTHER
COMMENTS FIGHTERS- SOMMAIRE
PATTERSON REMINDED ME ONE OF THE
THINGS WHEN I READ THE PROPOSAL
THAT I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT. IS
THE FOR EXCLUDING SOME OF THE
95% PROVIDERS YOU COULD HAVE
START UPS THAT COME AND TRY TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS. ARM BUT
I REALLY DO THINK WITH A CAP
OVER TEN YEARS WHAT WHAT I DON'T
SEE IS A CONTROL FOR THE
VIABILITY OF THE COMPANY. SO
THAT THEY DON'T GO BANKRUPT
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WOULD BE THE WORST OUTCOME FOR
US IS OF A SMALL COMPANY COMES
IN. RIGHT AND THE ABSENCE OF THE
BIG COMPANIES GOING IN SMALL
COMPANY COMES IN ALWAYS
SUPPORTER SMALL START UPS RIGHT
THAT'S GREAT THAT'S THAT'S GREAT
COME COMPETITION THAT'S FINE.
BUT THEY WOULD COME AND THEY
WOULD BE OVER AMBITIOUS AND WHEN
THEY ACTUALLY GO FOR THE TEN
YEARS THEY'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE
IT SO FIVE YEARS THEN. THEY GO
BANKRUPT DO WE HAVE A PLAN FOR
ONE OF THESE COMPANIES TO GET
THE FUNDING GO BANKRUPT WE HAVE.
IS THERE SOME FEEL SAFE THAT IS
BUILT INTO YOUR PROGRAM. TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE BANKRUPTCIES
THAT MAY HAPPEN. WHAT WE'RE NOT
PLANNING ON COMPANIES GOING
BANKRUPT I TAKE YOUR POINT. THAT
YOU SHOULD PLAN FOR COMPANIES
GOING BACK UP WE SHOULD ALWAYS
PLAN FOR COMPANIES. ESPECIALLY
WITH SO THAT'S MY CONCERN AROUND
THE TEN YEAR CAP AT FORTY
DOLLARS YOUR RETURN ON
INVESTMENT WORKS. OVER A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME BUT THE
MAINTENANCE OF THOSE LINES AND
YOU KNOW SO WHETHER WE HAVE SEA
LEVEL RISE AND- AN OCEAN SIDE OF
MY DISTRICT ARE YOUR FIRES OR
FLOODS YOU HAVE. OTHER THINGS
THAT WILL REQUIRE MAINTENANCE
AND THE SMALLER COMPANIES WILL
JUST NOT HAVE THE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL TO KEEP THAT OVER TIME
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE SOME
THOUGHT TO BE GIVEN. ON THE
VIABILITY OF THE COMPANY AND IF
THEY WERE ABLE ARE THE FULL
VIABILITY OF THE ORGANIZATION
HOWEVER IS PROVIDED. THE
FUNDING. HOW LIQUID THEY ARE TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE MAINTENANCE AND
COST OVER TIME. RIGHT MADAM
CHAIR IF I COULD JUST MAKE.
HEALTH POINTS COURTS FIRST IS
THAT OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS
WE'VE SEEN THE COST PER MEGABIT
DECLINED 90% SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FIFTY MEGABITS PER
SECOND. THE COST PER MEGABIT
DECLINING 90% OVER TEN YEARS.
THIS COULD BE AN ACADEMIC ISSUE
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S OTHER
FACTORS INVOLVED IN. INFLATION
YOU HAVE LABOR COSTS CETERA IT
SECOND POINT IS THAT THERE IS A
WAIVER PROCESS THAT WE INCLUDE
IN THE PROPOSED DECISION AND THE
COMMISSION COULD CERTAINLY TAKE
THAT INTO ACCOUNT AND PROVIDE
WAIVERS TO COMPANIES. I WOULD
OVER TO YOU NEXT I JUST WANT
REAL QUICKLY ON THE WAIVER- I
KNOW KNOWS THAT IN THE
INFORMATION YOU PUT THAT THIS-
C. P. U. C. IS REQUESTING 46% OF
POSITIONS TO. IMPLEMENT ON THE
WAY. ALSO ACTED MINISTER THE
WAIVER PROCESS- I'M JUST WANTING
TO UNDERSTAND MORE ABOUT THE
POSITIONS RELATED TO THE WAIVERS
AND WHAT HOW YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT THAT- THE FORTY SIX
POSITIONS ARE NOT TO IMPLEMENT
THE WAIVER PROCESS THERE TO
IMPLEMENT THE VARIOUS FUNDING
PROGRAMS THAT I WENT THROUGH. SO
IT'S NOT JUST FOR THE WAIVER NOW
BECAUSE I WAS GETTING VERY
NERVOUS THEY GET A FAIR EXPECTED
A LOT OF WAIVERS- ALL RIGHT SO
IT'S FOR ALL OF THE WORK FOR ALL
RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER. JUST AS A
GENERAL. BACK COMMENT HERE TO
LET. EVERYBODY ON THIS DIET
WANTS THIS DONE. THE PRIVATE
SECTOR ONCE THIS DONE I'VE BEEN
ON THIS COMMITTEE GOING ON TEN
YEARS NOW AND WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS WE BANNED NOT TAKING
MONEY FROM RATEPAYERS PUT IT IN
FUNDS WE WANT THIS DONE. HOW CAN
YOU ASSURE MEMBERS HERE THAT THE
P. YOU SEE IS NOT GOING TO BE.
OUR THE S. HOLD UP IN ALL OF
THIS. M. IN MIKE ALMOST TEN
YEARS HERE BUT THE PC'S BEEN
MORE THE PROBLEM THAT'S BEEN A
SOLUTION. SO MY QUESTION IS WHY
WE HAVE LOTS OF INTEREST LOTS OF
MONEY. AND YET I JUST SAT
THROUGH A BUNCH OF SLIDES AND A
BUNCH OF. TIMELINES AND A BUNCH
OF. BUREAUCRATIC. HOW CAN WE
HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO GET OUT OF THE WAY AND
LET THIS GET DONE INSTEAD OF
BEING THE STICK IN THE MUD. WELL
I WOULD POINT TO OUR TRACK
RECORD WITH THE CALIFORNIA VANCE
SERVICES FUND IN ISSUING GRANTS.
TO PROVIDE LAST MILE FUNDING.
AND GETTING PROGRAMS UP AND
GOING IN CALIFORNIA. JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE FORTY DOLLAR
PLAN FOR FIFTY MEGABITS PER
SECOND. IN BORING CALIFORNIA
THERE'S A COMPANY THAT WE FUNDED
THE PROVIDES GIGABIT SERVICE.
FOR SIXTY DOLLARS A MONTH USING
FIBER OPTIC. AND THAT IS A
PRODUCT OF THE CALIFORNIA EBT
SERVICES FUND. WELL WE WILL SEE
HOW THIS ALL GOES MY GUESS IS
WE'LL BE BACK HERE. ASKING SOME
TOUGH QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT'S
TAKING SO LONG. THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS ARE IF WE DON'T
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHER HANDS UP WE WILL
THANK YOU WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A
DIFFICULT- COMPLEX- MANDATE THAT
HAS BEEN UP. MOVE FOR FORWARD BY
THIS LEGISLATION AND WE I THINK
WE ALL HAVE THE SAME- THING IN
MIND WHICH IS. LET'S JUST GET
THIS DONE AS TIMELY AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU BUT
AFTER THINKING MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT NEXT WE WILL COME TO OUR
NEXT PART OF THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING OR LAST MILE BROADBAND
CONNECTING THE UNSERVED AND THAT
IS ITEM NUMBER THREE THE LAST
MILE FUNDING. WE HAVE COMING TO
US FROM CALAVERAS COUNTY.
CALAVERAS COUNTY SUPERVISOR JACK
GARAMENDI. AND KERRY ASK YOU
BAILEY WHO IS- THE GROUP VICE
PRESIDENT OF STATE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR CHARTER
COMMUNICATIONS- I WILL JUST
EXTEND I BELIEVE IT'S HE'S YOUR
UNCLE FATHER FATHER OKAY WELL I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF MEETING HIM
ONE TIME MANY YEARS AGO UP HERE-
WELCOME. AND ARE YOU LEADING US
OFF I WASN'T SURE WHAT I WAS
GOING FIRST I THINK WE HAVE YOU
GOING FIRST SUPERVISOR ALL RIGHT
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SPORT MY NAME IS
JACK ARMENIAN I AM COUNTY
SUPERVISOR FROM CALAVERAS COUNTY
SPOTTER OUR IN HOUSE SOUTH EAST
OF SACRAMENTO- I REPRESENT THE
SECOND. DISTRICT THERE. I'M ALSO
THE CHAIR OF THE NEWLY CREATED
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY GOLDEN
STATE CONNECTED STORY WHICH I
WANT TO EXPLAIN FURTHER IN OUR
COMMENTS ON HOW WE'RE GOING TO
BUILD INTERNET. ACCESSIBILITY
FOR RURAL CALIFORNIA I
APPRECIATE THE ABILITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE THE SCREEN TODAY ON THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT SAID BEFORE
US. I WANT TO ADDRESS HOW THE
INFLUX OF BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING FOR THE
MONUMENTAL SHIFT IN STATE
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT POLICY
COMBINED WITH THE INNOVATION
THAT IS GOING WITH INNOVATION.
IS GOING TO MAKE A REAL
MEANINGFUL CHANGE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. AS A SUPERVISOR
REPRESENTING A RURAL AREA AND
MEMBER OF THE RULE. COUNTY
REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIA CHINOS
RC RC MY COMMENTS HERE TODAY
WILL FOCUS ON HOW WE CAN. THESE
CHANGES PROVIDE INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY COVER 50% OF ALL
HOUSEHOLDS THE LACK RELIABLE
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND. PROVIDING
EQUITABLE INTERNET ACCESS TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT REGARD TO
INCOME OR LOCATION IS A GOAL
THAT I SHARE WITH THE STATE. AND
THIS PANEL AND I AM EXCITED TO
TELL YOU HOW LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CAN BE AND WILL BE LEADING
PARTNER IN THIS EFFORT. THE NEED
FOR RELIABLE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
FOR EVERY RESIDENTS IN THE STATE
IS SELF EVIDENT. THE INTERNET IS
NOW PUBLIC NECESSITY AND A VITAL
SERVICE IT DRIVES OUR BUSINESSES
ARE HEALTH EDUCATION AND MANY
WAYS OUR FUTURE. AND THAT IS WHY
WE AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
FOCUSING FOCUSED ON INNOVATIVE
WAYS TO UTILIZE THE GOOD WORK
THAT THIS BODY DEAD LAST YEAR TO
BRING FORWARD QUALITY INTERNET
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS. HEY MR
OSBORNE CENTER BEFORE'S DETAILED
HIS PRESENTATION SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS WERE MADE IN
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH
BUDGET SB ONE FIFTY SIX LAST
YEAR. I WANT TO FOCUS MY
COMMENTS PRIMARILY ON TWO OF
THOSE FUNDING PROGRAMS THE
FEDERAL FUNDING ACCOUNT. FF A
PER GRANT PROGRAM AND THE LOAN
LOSS RESERVE ACCOUNT THAT LOL
ARE PERFECT OUT. AND HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN BEST LEVERAGE
THOSE INVESTMENTS THE FIRST I
WANTED US TO POLICY CHANGE MADE
LAST YEAR IN ADDITION TO THE
FUNDING AND HOW THOSE THINGS
HAVE WORKED TOGETHER TO CREATE A
PARADIGM SHIFT IN HOW THE STATE
SUPPORTS BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT. I
BELIEVE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE POLICY CHANGES PARALLELS A
PROCESS THAT OUR COUNTRY IS WELL
ACQUAINTED WITH AND THAT WAS
SUCCESSFUL IN BETTERING THE
LIVES OF MANY RURAL. AMERICANS
THE RULE ELECTRIFICATION ACT. IN
193690% OF FARMS IN THE UNITED
STATES LACKED ELECTRICITY. MANY
OF THESE FORMS ORIGINAL
HOMESTEADS INCENTIVIZE
CULTIVATED LAND IN EIGHTEEN
SIXTY TWO HOMESTEAD ACT. AS
ELECTRICITY. BECAME MORE
COMMONPLACE IN CITIES. THE RULE
AREAS BIG. CONSEQUENTLY MORE
DARK AS PRIVATE ELECTRICAL
COMPANIES SKEPTICAL ABOUT
RECOUPING COSTS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE CHOOSE NOT TO
DELIVER POWER TO THESE AREAS. TO
RAISE THE STANDARD OF ROLE
HAVING PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT
ESTABLISHED THE RULE
ELECTRIFICATION ACT. WHICH
PROVIDED LOW INTEREST LOANS TO
BUILD LINES AND PROVIDE SERVICE
WHERE FOR PROFIT UTILITIES WOULD
NOT. EARLY ON IN THIS PROGRAM IT
BECAME VERY CLEAR THAT INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES WERE NOT
INTERESTED IN FEDERAL LOANS. BUT
HOWEVER LOCAL COMMUNITY
COOPERATIVES WORK. MOST OF THE
RURAL INFRASTRUCTURE UNITED
STATES TODAY IS A PRODUCT OF
THESE LOCALLY OWNED NOT FOR
PROFIT RULE ELECTRICAL COOPS.
HISTORICALLY THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS ATTEMPTED
TO INCENTIVIZE BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT BY SUBSIDIZING
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS FOR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
THAT PROVIDE SERVICE AND HIGH
COST UNDERSERVED AREAS.
UNFORTUNATELY ALTHOUGH THE STATE
HAS BEEN FUNDING DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND TO BRIDGE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE THE BRIDGE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE FOR FIFTEEN YEARS. WE ARE
HERE AGAIN. STILL TODAY TALKING
ABOUT THE NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT ACCESS TO
HIGH SPEED INTERNET. I BELIEVE
THAT IS WHY THIS BODY DECIDED IT
WAS TIME TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. AS PRESIDENT
ROOSEVELT DID OVER EIGHTY YEARS
AGO UNLIKE THE RULE AMERICANS
THAT BANDED TOGETHER TO BRING
ELECTRICITY TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE JOINED TOGETHER NOW TO
LEVERAGE THE PUBLIC FUNDING AND
PROGRAMS ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR
TO FINALLY BRING BROADBAND TO
OUR COMMUNITIES. THE POLICY
CHANGES MADE LAST YEAR EMPOWER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROVIDE
BROADBAND SERVICE TO THE
RESIDENTS LEGISLATION REMOVE
BARRIERS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO RECEIVE CALIFORNIA ADVANCE
SERVICES FUNDS GRANTS FOR LAST
MILE INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS IT
CREATED. THE LOCAL AGENCY
TECHNICAL ASSIST ON THE CLEATED
ADMITS AND PREPARING. FOR
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT IN THE
RESPECTIVE JURISDICTIONS AND
MADE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ELIGIBLE
FOR GRANTS TO THE FEDERAL
FUNDING ACCOUNT. SB ONE FIFTY
SIX ALSO ESTABLISHED A LOAN LOSS
RESERVE FUND CREATED
SPECIFICALLY FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
AND JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY'S JPA
IS. TO LEVERAGE. THE CAPITAL FOR
PRIVATE FUNDING A BROADBAND
DEPLOYMENT. TOGETHER THESE
CHANGES HAVE ALLOWED THE
FORMATION OF THE GOLDEN STATE
CONNECT THE THORGY JPA WHICH
COMPRISES OF THIRTY NINE
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES. WITH THE
MISSION TO BUILD OPEN ACCESS
PUBLICLY FUNDED PUBLICLY OWNED
FIBER CONNECTIONS TO THE HOME OF
UNDERSERVED RESIDENTS GOLDEN
STATE CONNECTED STORY OR GS CA
ISN'T INNOVATIVE MODEL FOR
DEPLOYMENT US WILL BROADBAND.
OUR BASED UPON A PIONEER PROGRAM
IN UTAH CALLED UTOPIA FIBER
WHICH HAS SUCCESSFULLY DESIGNED
BUILT AND OPERATED OVER THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF FIBER PROJECTS IN FIFTY
DIFFERENT CITIES. RC RC STAFF
HAS BEEN WORKING FOR NEARLY TWO
YEARS WITH UTOPIA. REPLICATE A
MODEL THAT WILL WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. PROBLEM THE PROGRAM
IS QUITE SIMPLE IN CONCEPT
GOLDEN STATE CONNECTED THIRTY
WILL USE FUNDS AWARDED FROM THE
CPUC LOAN LOSS RESERVE FUND TO
SECURE REVENUE BONDS ISSUED BY
OUR GPA TO FUND CONSTRUCTION OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS
PROCESS ALLOWS GOLD STAY
CONNECTED TOWARD TO LEVERAGE
PUBLIC LOW MUST RESERVE FUNDS TO
SECURE FIVE EIGHT TIMES THE LAST
LOAN LOSS RESERVE AMOUNT THROUGH
BOND ISSUANCE. AS I STATED THIS
IS FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
OPEN ACCESS PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE. MEANING THAT
MANY INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
WILL BE ABLE TO USE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE CREATING
COMPETITION IN OPTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS. PUT SIMPLY THIS MODEL
WILL ALLOW PRIVATE CAPITAL. TO
BUILD BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
AS OPPOSED TO THE FULLY
SUBSIDIZED PATIENT BOUGHT. THAT
THE STATE HAS TYPICALLY AND
TRADITIONALLY USED. IN ORDER TO
START CONSTRUCTION FAST AND I
KNOW THAT WAS THE ISSUE EARLIER
IN THIS COMMITTEE. GOLDEN STATE
CONNECT THE TORTILLAS LOOKING AT
PROJECT AREAS THAT WILL BE IT
THAT WILL BE VIABLE BUT THE
FEDERAL FUND OUT ACCOUNT GRANTS
ALONE WELL THE CPUC CONCERT
CONTINUES TO CONSIDER. THE LOAN
LOSS RESERVE. AUTISTIC CONNECT
IS ALSO WORKING TO MAKE SURE
COUNTIES ARE PREPARED FOR
BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT. AS THE
FUNDING BEGINS TO FLOW. WE ARE
OFFERING APPLICATION SUPPORT TO
MEMBER COUNTIES FOR THE LOCAL
AGENCY TECHNICAL ASSISTANT GRANT
FUND WHICH IS DESIGNED TO HELP
FUND PRE DEVELOPMENT WORK. SUCH
AS SPEED OF FEASIBILITY STUDIES
CONTRACT DEVELOPMENT AND INITIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS. LASTLY RC
RC HAS APPLIED FOR FEDERAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
FUNDING ON BEHALF OF ITS
MEMBERS. TO COMPLETE BROADBAND
PLAN THE TWENTY SEVEN REMAINING.
MANY MEMBER COUNTIES WITHOUT A
CURRENT BROADBAND DEPLOYMENT
PLAN. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
GOLDEN STATE CONNECT THIRTY
TODAY. WE INVEST MUCH THE LAST
TWO YEARS AND PREPARING. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE RIGHT
BEFORE US RIGHT NOW. AND WE'RE
READY TO START BUILDING THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND GET OUR
COMMUNITIES CONNECTED.
IMMEDIATELY THANK YOU MANAGER
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
REFERENCE TO. IN NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX TO RURAL ELECTRIFICATION.
GOOD GOOD- INFORMATION AND
TIMELY IN THE SENSE THAT THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ENROLL A BIG
INITIATIVE HERE- WITH THAT JUST
I HAVE A QUESTION WHICH IS- THAT
YOU HAVE DONE A PROJECT IN LOS
ANGELES. RELATED TO. OUT WRONG
WRONG PERSON. BUT I WILL BE
ASKING THAT QUESTION AT THE LOS
ANGELES PROP- PRODUCT DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
HERE WE HAVE MEMBERS GOING BACK
AND FORTH TO COMMITTEE SO WE'RE
LOSING SOME PEOPLE HERE SO I
APOLOGIZE- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
NOT SEEN ANY WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS THAN WE HAVE KERRY
ASK YOU BAILEY. WELCOME THANK
YOU THAT MADAM CHAIRWOMAN IN
MEMBERS IT IS AN HONOR TO
REPRESENT CHARTER COMMUNICATIONS
TODAY CHARTER IS A LEADING
BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY COMPANY
AND CABLE OPERATOR WE SERVE MORE
THAN FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
CUSTOMERS ACROSS TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ALONE WE EXPANDED OUR NETWORK TO
REACH AN ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY NINE THOUSAND HOMES
AND BUSINESSES IN THE STATE.
WHERE AN OVERALL CAPITAL
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA OF ONE
POINT ONE BILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND OUR NETWORK IS
SUPPORTED BY JUST OVER EIGHTY
THREE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES HERE IN
THE STATE WE ARE PROUD OF THE
WORK WE'RE DOING LOCALLY AND
ACROSS THE NATION AND ARE FORTY
ONE STATE FOOTPRINT THE STATE'S
BROADBAND EXPANSION EFFORTS HAVE
ACTUALLY BANNED IN OUR OPINION
FAIRLY SUCCESSFUL- ACCORDING TO
THE FCC'S MOST RECENT DATA OVER
99% OF URBAN AREAS HAVE ACCESS
TO HIGH SPEED BROADBAND. AND NOW
WE REALLY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE PROGRESS- IN CONNECTING
MORE RURAL CALIFORNIANS A ONLY
84% ASH- OF WHOM HAVE ACCESS
CONNECTING THESE NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNSERVED
CALIFORNIANS WILL REQUIRE A
SUSTAINED PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP SINCE I'D CHARTER
HAS BEEN AT AN ACTIVE PARTNER IN
THE STATE'S BUILD OUT EFFORTS
SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN THROUGH
THE CASTS OF PROGRAM WHICH WE'VE
TALKED A LOT ABOUT TODAY- WE'VE
PARTICIPATED IN MORE THAN
SIXTEEN CATHOLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROJECTS INCLUDING
IMPLEMENTING THIRTEEN MILLION OF
GRANT FUNDING FROM THIS PAST
CYCLE ALONE. WE ALSO ASSIST
STEEP IN IT. AT TO VERIFY THAT
THERE ARE- THAT THEY ARE TRULY
FOCUSING MONEY ON UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. WE DO THAT THROUGH
THE CHALLENGE PROCESS IN KASA.
IN VIRTUALLY EVERY CHALLENGE
THAT CHARTER HAS SUBMITTED WE
HAVE SUCCEEDED IN HELPING THE P.
YOU SEE- AND THAT'S EITHER
THROUGH- RIGHT SIZING PROJECTS
TO FOCUS ON UNSERVED AREAS OR
THROUGH OTHER MEANS- JUST TO
ADDRESS THE ONGOING PROCEEDING
I'LL I'LL MOVE THAT UP TO THE
FRONT OF THE COMMENTS HERE ON
THE F. FEDERAL FUNDING TO COUNT
MANY OF YOU IN THIS ROOM
ACTUALLY HELPED CREATE THAT
ACCOUNT AND IT REALLY DOES.
PRESENT AND AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO CONNECT
UNSERVED CALIFORNIANS BUT ONLY
IF A WIDE VARIETY OF ENTITIES
ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM AND- LET ME BE CLEAR
AFTER REVIEWING. THE RED LINE
CHANGES RELEASED YESTERDAY- IT
IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT OUR
COMPANY WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM-
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE FURTHER
MODIFICATIONS THAT ARE CRITICAL-
WE WOULD URGE THE P. YOU SEEK TO
DELAY TOMORROW'S ACTION AND
ACTUALLY ADDRESS AND REMOVE. THE
BARRIERS TO PARTICIPATION THAT
WE SEE IN THE CURRENT DRAFT A
HIGHLIGHT THREE OF THEM FOR YOU
QUICKLY- FIRST OF ALL THE
PROPOSED MANDATE FOR A GENERALLY
AVAILABLE AS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED
EVEN TO WEALTHY CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS. LOW COST PLAN AT
SPEEDS OF FIFTY OVER FIFTY FOR
FORTY DOLLARS PER MONTH FOR THE
LIFE OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SHOULD BE REPLACED. IT IS AN
UNNECESSARY REQUIREMENT GIVEN
CHARTER AND MANY OTHER. ALREADY
OFFER TO PULL LOW COST PLANS
AVAILABLE TO A BROAD GROUP OF
HOUSEHOLDS. IN ADDITION CHARTER
ALONG WITH MANY OTHER PROVIDERS
HAVE ANNOUNCED A HUNDRED
MEGABITS DOWNLOAD SERVICE THAT
WILL BE FREE TO HOUSEHOLDS THAT
QUALIFY UNDER THE ACP PROGRAM.
IF HERE'S CONCERN THAT THE
PUBLIC IS NOT BENEFITING ENOUGH
FROM THE ATP CALIFORNIA HAS THE
ABILITY TO FUND AN EXPANDED
SUBSIDY FOR ADDITIONAL
HOUSEHOLDS. IT IS MUCH MORE
BENEFICIAL TO THE PUBLIC HAVE
BROADBAND AVAILABLE THANKS
MICROMANAGE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
OFFERED AND FORCE DISCOUNTS BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO WEALTHY
HOUSEHOLDS ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES. ON ENTITIES. THE SECOND
THING THE CPUC NEEDS TO ADDRESS
IS- WE WOULD ARGUE THEY SHOULD
MAINTAIN THE EXISTING PASSIVE
TWO YEAR PRICE FREEZE INSTEAD OF
THE PROPOSED TEN YEAR CAP THAT
WOULD IN FACT LIMIT PARTICIPANTS
ABILITY TO SUPPORT NETWORK
MAINTENANCE AND UPGRADES CHARTER
HAS A NATIONAL PRICING AND
PACKAGING STRUCTURE CONSUMERS IN
AREAS THAT HAVE LESS COMPETITION
BENEFIT GREATLY FROM THAT MODEL
AS IT IS ORIENTED TOWARD
ENSURING OUR PRICES IN PACKAGING
IT ARE COMPETITIVE IN THE MOST
WELL SERVED AND COMPETITIVE
MARKETS. AND THIRD WE BELIEVE IN
CREATING THE STREAMLINED
CHALLENGE PROCESS THE CPUC
REALLY NEEDS TO BALANCE SPEED
WITH ACCURACY WHILE ARGUABLY THE
REDLINE- THAT WAS RELEASED
YESTERDAY IS SOMEWHAT IMPROVED
FROM THE INITIAL DRAFT WE STILL
BELIEVE THE PROPOSED PROCESS IS
OVERLY BURDENSOME AND WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
TO FOCUS PUBLIC RESOURCES ON
AREAS THAT LACKS. THIS IN THE
VOLUME OF DOCUMENTATION THAT
WILL BE REQUIRED WE THINK WILL
TAKE LONGER TO REVIEW AND
ANALYZE RATHER THAN ACHIEVING
THE GOAL OF STREAMLINING. OUR
BUILD OUT EXPERIENCE EXPANDING
AND UPGRADING OUR SYSTEM HAS
REVEALED INSIGHTS INTO THE
CHALLENGES THAT CAN EXIST WITH
LAST MILE CONNECTIVITY. WE OFTEN
SAY THAT IN EVERY UNSERVED AREA
THERE IS A STORY AND WHETHER
THAT'S AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY THAT
SON SERVED A NEIGHBORHOOD THAT'S
UNSERVED OR A DONUT HOLE THAT
WAS SPOKEN OF BEFORE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS OFTEN NOT-
ONE A STORY OF THE PROVIDERS
MAKING. FOR EXAMPLE FOR OVER
FOUR YEARS CHARTER TRIED TO
NAVIGATE THE CALTRANS RIGHT OF
WAY PERMITTING PROCESS TO REACH
THE COMMUNITY OF ALL TERRORISTS
IN MODOC COUNTY. RESIDENTS THERE
COULD HAVE ENJOYED ACCESS TO OUR
NATIONAL PACKAGING AND YOU THINK
PUTTING BROADBAND SPEED OF UP TO
A GAG UNFORTUNATELY AS I SIT
HERE TODAY WE ARE NO CLOSER TO
CONNECTING ALTURAS. IN OTHER
INSTANCES WE ROAD WE RUN INTO
ROAD BLOCKS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WE HAVE NUMEROUS
EXAMPLES AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHERE RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES ASK US TO BRING THEM
SERVICE. AND YET WE ARE NOT ABLE
TO MEET THAT DEMAND DUE TO
LENGTHY PERMITTING PROCESSES AND
THE THESE. INSTANCES THOSE BUT
IT'S FAR OVERSTEPPED THE IMPACTS
ON ACCOUNT ACCESSING THE PUBLIC
RIGHT OF WAY. IN ADDITION ARE
FACING AN EVER CHANGING IT
LITORIA ENVIRONMENT WITH EVER
INCREASING REQUIREMENTS DOES
CREATE BUSINESS UNCERTAINTY AND
ACCIDENTS A DISINCENTIVE FOR
GREATER INVESTMENT. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WHEN CHARTER BUILDS TO OR
UPGRADES AN AREA WE DO SO TO THE
WHOLE AREA DECISIONS ARE BASED
ON THE COST TO BUILD AND THE
DENSITY OF THE AREA NOT INCOME
LEVELS WELL URBAN AND RURAL
PROJECTS FACE THEIR OWN UNIQUE
CHALLENGES I WILL HIGHLIGHT AND
NOTE THAT RURAL AREAS
UNFORTUNATELY ARE OFTENTIMES
SIMPLY MORE DIFFICULT AND
EXPENSIVE TO REACH- THEY AND
BARBARA INVOLVED VAST. LARGER
PROJECTS THEY HAVE MUCH LOWER
POPULATION DENSITIES AND THEY DO
REQUIRE GREATER OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT FROM TECHNICIANS GIVEN
THE LARGE GEOGRAPHIES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- ALSO MEANT REALLY
MENTION REALLY QUICKLY THE NEED
TO ATTACHED TO UTILITY POLES.
MAYBE THE BEST OPTION BUT IT'S
OFTEN A SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF
DELAY AND ADDITIONAL COST FOR
EXAMPLE IN OUR URBAN AREA YOU
MAY BE ABLE TO REACH TEN HOMES
BY ATTACHING TO IT THANGAL ALL.
IN OUR AREA THAT CAN BE FLIPPED
LET'S HEAD AND IT COULD TAKE
ATTACHING TO TENTPOLES TO REACH
ONE HOME AND NOT PULL IT UP TO
MY PROCESS CAN BE LENGTHY. I
THANK YOU FOR BEING US DEPART.
DAY AND I WILL BEG YOUR
INDULGENCE I DO HAVE ONE OF OUR
REGULAR- EXPERT TOWARD FIRST
HERE WITH IF WE- VERY TO AREAS
MORE HIS EXPERTISE AND QUESTIONS
I'LL ASK THAT HE- JOIN US. THANK
YOU THAT WAS VERY OFFENSIVE AND
I THINK WE ALL CONTINUE TO LEARN
ON THIS COMMITTEE- ALL OF THE
EXTENSIVE PROCESSES AND SCOPE
YOU NEED TO GO THROUGH- I WILL
OPEN IT UPTO QUESTIONS I HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS BUT- ALLOW THE
MEMBERS. SO RELATED TO CHARTER
THAN- I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE TO
USE THESE GRANTS AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WANTED TO KNOW
IS- THAT YOU'RE ONE OF THE FEW
THAT HAVE APPLIED FOR THE GRANTS
IN URBAN AREAS YOU DID HAVE A
PROJECT IN LOS ANGELES TO
CONNECT TO A TRAILER PARK
SERVICE CAN YOU TALK ABOUT HOW
IT WOULD IDENTIFIED THAT AREA AS
A PROJECT AND HOW WAS THAT THE
NATION WITH THE PROPERTY OWNER
AS WE KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN SOME
OF THE- SENATE SOMETIMES- IF YOU
WANT THE SAME UP HOMES THE
CHOSEN NOT TO MOVE FORWARD YEAH
SO WE YOU WILL. WE WILL NOTICE I
MEAN ALL OF IT IS PUBLIC RIGHT-
OUR FIRST TWO ROUNDS OF
PARTICIPATION IN THE PROGRAM
WERE SOMEWHAT HEAVILY WEIGHTED
TOWARD MOBILE HOME PARKS
OBVIOUSLY WE THOSE THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES NEED TO BE CONNECTED
JUST LIKE ALL OF. BUT OF THAT
WAS DUE TO CHALLENGES
IDENTIFYING ELIGIBLE AREAS SO
THE PRIOR ELIGIBILITY WAS SIX
HAVE BUY ONE. SERVICE AND THE
NEW ELIGIBILITY IS TWENTY FIVE
BY THREE SO IT IT WE BELIEVE
GOING FORWARD THERE WILL BE MORE
AREAS THAT THAT WILL BE
IDENTIFIED- WE DID HAVE TO
RETURN SOME OF OUR GRANT OF
FUNDS. BECAUSE WE WERE NOT ABLE
TO ACCESS PROPERTY BASED ON
RIGHT OF ENTRY WE CAN'T ACCESS
PROPERTY UNLESS WE HAVE
PERMISSION- AND IN A FEW
INSTANCES IN THOSE MOBILE HOME
PARKS WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE THAT WITH. THE PARK
OWNERS SO IT IT CAN CREATE A
BARRIER WHETHER IT'S PUBLIC
PROPERTY WE HAVE OTHER ISSUES
GOING ON AND- IN SOME AREAS
AROUND PUBLIC PROPERTY AND
CHALLENGES TRYING TO GET
PERMISSION BUT BUT RIGHT OF
ENTRY CAN BE AN ISSUE. AND DO
YOU HAVE ANY IDEA JUST ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA JUST
LOOKING OUT MOBILE HOMES- ANY
TYPE OF PERCENTAGE OF THOSE WHO
ARE CONNECTED VERSUS THOSE WHO
ARE NOT CONNECTED. I DO NOT.
THAT WOULD BE AN INTERESTING
INFORMATION BECAUSE WHEN WE KNOW
THERE ARE MORE IF YOU WANT TO
SAY SENIORS BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THEIR YOUNG FAMILIES THAT ARE
LIVING AND SOME OF THESE BUT
THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING FOR US
TO RESEARCH. AND THEN ONE A
QUESTION ABOUT CALAVERAS- WHAT
IS YOUR RESPONSE TO CRITICS WHO
WOULD SAY THAT THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULDN'T BE INVOLVED IN
BROADBAND- I WOULD SAY THAT. I
WOULD I THINK WE WOULD ALL BE
HAPPIER IF WE KNEW THAT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR CONSERVE ALL THE
PARTS CALIFORNIA BUT AS AS MISS
BAILEY POINTED OUT. IT'S NOT
LIKELY FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
REASONS SO WE COULD ASK THE SAME
QUESTION WHY WOULD. NONPROFIT
CLUBS BE PART OF
ELECTRIFICATION. THE JOBS NEEDED
TO HAPPEN WE NEED TO PROVIDE
SERVICE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
RURAL AND URBAN. AND SELL-
UNFORTUNATELY THE GOVERNMENT'S
GOING TO HAVE TO STEP INTO THIS
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE GOOD PRACTICE
AT PROVIDING INFRASTRUCTURE.
ROADS PLAN MONEY FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL MINING. WE BUILD FEDERAL
THE HIGHWAYS YOU BUILD THE HOT
YOU BILL THE STATE HIGHWAYS WE
BUILD THE LOCAL ROADS AND WE
LET. INDIVIDUALS AND COMPANIES
RUN STOREFRONTS. SO THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE TO BE THERE BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO OUR
PEOPLE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BOULDERS- YES- MISS BAILEY WOULD
YOU SAY THAT THE PRICE CAPS AND
OTHER ELEMENTS OF THE P. YOU
SEE- OF THE PUC'S RULES ARE
DISCOURAGING YOUR PARTICIPATION
. YES ANY EXPANSION ON THAT OR
OF I MEAN I THINK WHAT WE ARE
CONCERNED FOR A LOT OF THE
REASONS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED- IN TERMS OF NOT ONLY
ARBITRARY. PRICE CAPS THAT BEN
ARE FIXED IN TIME AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT THERE MAY BE A
WAIVER PROCESS I THINK YOU KNOW
WE JUST GOT A LOOK AT THAT
YESTERDAY- I THINK WE STILL.
OBVIOUSLY IT IS A DISCRETIONARY
IF YOU WILL SO THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT APPLYING FOR A
WAIVER YOU'RE GOING TO GET ONE-
WE ALSO THINK IN SOME WAYS IT'S
A LITTLE BIT OF A CONFUSING
PROCESS AND TORY COULD DRILL
DOWN. ON DETAILS MORE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE- BUT ALSO- I THINK WE
HAVE CONCERNS THAT GOING FORWARD
YOU KNOW WITH THE BEAT PROGRAM
ANY ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT'S
COMING DOWN YOU'RE SETTING THAT
YOU KNOW THAT THAT PC IS
ATTEMPTING TO SET. ONE PARAMETER
WITH THIS BUCKET OF MONEY CAST
IF ALREADY HAS AN EXISTING TWO
YEAR PRICE FREEZE THAT WE THINK
IS WORKING WELL THERE MAY BE
SOME ROOM TO GO BETWEEN TWO YEAR
AND TEN BUT NOW YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A TWO YEAR AND THEN THIS
BUCKET OF MONEY. IS GOING TO BE
A TEN YEAR AND THEN. MAYBE THE
STATE PLAN THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PUTS TOGETHER THREE LEGISLATION
HAS A DIFFERENT VISION AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU GO BACK TO THE
REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY ISSUE
AND- WHICH BUCKET ARE WE
APPLYING FOR AND HOW AND HOW DO
YOU. REGIONAL LIES THAT- AS A
COMPANY- FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
IT'S A CHALLENGE AND IT'S
UNNECESSARY. BECAUSE COMPANIES
ALREADY HAVE. LOW COST PROGRAMS
IN THE MARKET PLACE AS I
MENTIONED COMPANIES HAVE
COMMITTED. TO ADDITIONAL STEPS
WITH HIGHER SPEEDS FOR ACP
QUALIFIED HOMES AND THE STATE
ABSOLUTELY HAS THE WHERE WITH
ALL. TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THROUGH ADDITIONAL SUBSIDIES IF.
THE CONCERN IS THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON ON THE CUSP
AND MAY NOT QUALIFY FOR SOME OF
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS. MAY NEED
A LITTLE HELP IT'S BETTER TO
REALLY GO IN AND SURGICALLY
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. THEN JUST
CREATE THIS SWEEPING- MANDATE
THAT THAT IS GOING TO MAKE IT-
HIGHLY UNLIKELY I WILL SAY THAT
COMPANIES ARE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE. YEAH I WOULD JUST
ADD THAT YOU KNOW MY
UNDERSTANDING OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW- BALA TILE
THE ECONOMY IS RIGHT NOW WITH
INFLATION THAT IT WOULD BE SCARY
FOR ANY BUSINESS TO. BE ABLE TO
COMMIT TO A TENURE- PRICE FREEZE
SO USING. DATA AND INFORMATION
AND PROGRAMS ALREADY EXIST THAT
WE KNOW SUCH AS MAYBE TO YOUR
FEES WHICH I THINK IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD DEFINITELY LOOK
INTO DID YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING TO. FOR MONEY FROM-
GONE SICKENING THREAT I WE HAVE
LOOKED AT THIS AS WELL WE DON'T
HAVE THE SAME CONSTRAINTS IS A
PRIVATE COMPANY DOES. WE DON'T
HAVE TO RETURN HAVE A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR INVESTORS. WE
REPRESENT THE PUBLIC SO WE WILL
RECEIVE THIS THIS BOND. ISSUE
AND THAT IS FIXED PRICE SO WE
ARE IN DIFFERENT POSITIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER HANDS UP SO WITH THAT-
I'M SORRY WAS THE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT A REVENUE BASE BOND YES
SIR OKAY WELL THEN YOU GOT TO
HAVE THE REVENUE TO PAY THE
REVENUE BASE BOND THAT'S CORRECT
THAT'S GOING TO DEPEND ON.
ADOPTION AND ALL KINDS OF MARKET
FACTORS AS WELL SO THERE'S A
RISK THERE. YES SIR. WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE FROM
. TESTIMONY HERE IN TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND FIRST WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES. ARE WE
GOING TO DO THE PEACEFUL. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR SO MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN OPEN THE LINES AND IF YOU
COULD LET US KNOW HOW MANY.
PEOPLE WE HAVE ON LINES OR
ESTIMATE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
BY PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AND I WOULD ADD THAT WE
ARE LIMON THIRTEEN- PUBLIC
COMMENT TO ONE MINUTE UPPER
CALLERS PLEASE ONE MINUTE. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN Q.
GO TO OUR FIRST PLANE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SHARED MEMBERS MADE SO LOVE
ON BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS WE SERVE NEARLY
ONE MILLION CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE BEEN
AWARDED. A TWENTY. BED SERVICES
FUND GRANTS OVER THE YEARS- WE
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY CHARTER
COMMUNICATIONS- YOU KNOW WE
SHARE THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
TOMORROW'S VOTE IF YOU SEE AN AD
HOC THAT THOSE CAN BE POSTPONED
TO ADDRESS. THE ISSUES
DISCUSSED- WE ALSO AGREED THAT
THE TEN YEAR PRICE CAP IS TOO
LONG AND FOR THE CURRENT TWO
YEAR PRICE CAP- ALSO WANT TO
MAKE A QUICK NOTE THAT WE
SUPPORT THAT SHARES AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY NINE THE WHICH SEEKS
TO ACTUALLY STREAMLINED THE
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND. PROGRAMS
TO ENSURE THAT MORE FOLKS ARE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT AND
WE'RE CONCERNED AT TOMORROW'S
DECISION COULD ACTUALLY GO THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION SO.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
QUIRK-SILVA AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT THE QATAR MEDINA
WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL BUT WE HAVE THE
COMMITTEE TO REQUEST YOU TO P.
P. U. T. THAT TIED UP IN COURT
OR BE HELD UNTIL THE NEXT THE
BEAUTY VOTING MEETING ON APRIL
TWENTY FIRST. BUT THE DPT CAN
PROPERLY CONSIDERED NEW
INFORMATION AND REVISED THAT
THAT THAT THEY PROPOSED DECISION
ACCORDINGLY. RECENTLY SEVERAL
KEY INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT OUT NEW ONE HUNDRED MEGABIT
PER SECOND SERVICE PLANS ARE OR
WILL BE PROBABLY. AVAILABLE TO
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS. RECENT
ACTIONS BE. IN PP YOU THINK
MAKING PROCESS. ON HOW IT
ADDRESSES BROADBAND
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES IN THE FFA
PROGRAM ENDED THE FINAL AT THAT
THEY DECISION. AND WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT AND AN ADDITIONAL
TWO WEEKS WOULD ACTUALLY IMPACT
THE TTC'S ABILITY TO
SUCCESSFULLY EXECUTE THE PROGRAM
. IF IN FACT THAT THE DPP
DOESN'T CONSIDER THE TWO
INFORMATIONAL ENACTING A
PROPOSED DECISION ET THE
RECORDING PROGRAM PARTICIPATION
RESTRICTING THE ULTIMATE SUCCESS%
OF THE PROGRAM. THEREFORE WE'RE
OUT IN THE BEAUTY TO EXTEND IT
FINAL VOTE ON THE FFA TO ITS
NEXT MEETING ON APRIL TWENTY
FIRST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. THANK
YOU. EXCELLENT TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AGAIN CALIFORNIA TO
HAVE CONNECTICUT RESIDENTS FEEL
CALIFORNIA'S MANAGEMENT POST
COMMENTS AND WE ARE ASKING THE
COMMITTED DURING THE VIETNAM.
AND BAPTIST YOU SEE TO OUR
POSTPONED- YEAH COMMITTEE
HEARING ON ITEM FORTY FOUR.
APRIL TWENTY FIRST ARAMBULA YOU
PERFORM BUT THE PREVIOUS CALLER
AND ANY OTHER PEOPLE TESTIFIED
THAT- WE THINK THAT THE CPC
SHOULD CONSIDER WHICH APARTMENT.
I S. BE. LIKE A NEW LOW COST
SECOND ONE HUNDRED AND THAT ARE
PUTTING AND MAKE CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM WHAT PARTICIPATION BY I.
S. P. WHICH OF THAT SOME
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM
SHOULD INCLUDE REMOVING THE TEN
YEAR PARTS. CAP WHICH THIS
METABOLITE. SENATE BY THE
PROVIDER FOR MY PORTENT BEST. IN
NETWORKS OPERATE. AND ALSO FIFTY
BY FIFTY MEGABYTES IN A UP AND
SPEECH BUT SERVICEABLE. IS
REQUIRED IS THE SUBSTANCE TO
CURRENT OPTIONS LIKE TO SPECTRUM
ONE HUNDRED INTERNET AND IS NOT
ALIGNED WITH THE CONSUMER
INTERNET YES SO WE ASK YOU TO
ONE. TO RESPECTIVELY RECALL THAT
THE PIECE POSSIBLE- OUR APRIL
SEVENTH MEETING- PROPOSED THE
SIX. THANK YOU. NEXT TOTALING
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MARY BAGDASARIAN AND
I'M WITH THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO LIGHT WE'VE
SEEN ESPECIALLY DURING COLD IT
HOW IMPORTANT ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET IS AND- WE NEED TO
COLLECTIVELY MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERN MENTIONED BY OTHERS
DURING THIS HEARING AND I'M HERE
TO ASK THE COMMITTEE TO URGE THE
CPUC TO DELAY ACTION REGARDING
THE FAA RULES. DURING THEIR
MEETING TOMORROW AND DOING ANY
DECISION MAKING UNTIL THE
FOLLOWING MEETING APRIL TWENTY
FIRST TO GET STAKEHOLDERS MORE
TIME TO ADDRESS THE NUMBER OF
PROBLEMS THEY BRING OUT
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. WHAT THEY ARE
SET TO DISCUSS AND DECIDE ON
TOMORROW HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
INHIBIT ACCESS OF BROADBAND TO
THOSE IN OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. WELL THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS- BETTER
CURRENTLY DRAFTED WITHIN THE
RULES THEY'RE THE TWO THAT I
WANT TO MAKE NOTE ON WHICH IS
THE PROGRAM IS NOT LIMITED TO
LOW INCOME PEOPLE THIS MEANS
THAT THIS PROGRAM COULD BE
POTENTIALLY EXPLOITED BY MULTI
MILLIONAIRES. SO THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM IS NOT MEANT FOR THERE
FOR THOSE WHO THIS PROGRAM IS
MEANT FOR WILL END UP
SUBSIDIZING FOR EVERYONE ELSE IT
SETS A TEN YEAR CAMP CAP AS IT'S
BEEN MENTIONED ON THE PRICE OF
ACCESS. FOR THE CPUC TO
ARBITRARILY PUT A CAP WITHOUT
LOOKING INTO THE FULL SCOPE OF
SERVICE AND ACCESS WITHOUT
ALLOWING FOR ADDITIONAL RESEARCH
AN ADJUSTMENT. IT WILL INCREASE
THE COST IN HER ACCESS IT IS
MEANT TO PROVIDE. THANKS AGAIN
FOR YOUR NEEDS TODAY AND AGAIN I
ASK YOU TO URGENCY PC TO DELAY
ANY ACTION AND DECISION MAKING
FOR THOSE JUST TWO MORE WEEKS.
UNTIL TEIR NEXT MEETING AND
INSTEAD TO WORK TOGETHER WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND MORE
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION TO MEET. THE
NEEDS OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
THANK GOD M. I HAVE GAVEL NOW UP
I NEED TO RE. YOU THAT A ONE
MINUTE WE HAVE A TIE PLEASE KEEP
IT TO ONE MINUTE THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO ADDITIONAL LINE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY FOUR
LINES HAVE BEEN COMPLETED- WE
WILL PROCEED- WITH- COMMENTS
FROM THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM.
RIGHT THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU FOR THE
ROBUST ADD DIALOGUE TODAY AT
LEAST APPRECIATE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION HOW CALM ON THIS
FUNDING IS A ONCE IN A MULTIPLE
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY TO GET
CONNECTIVITY THE MOST RURAL
REACHES OF OUR STATE AND THE
SMALL LACKS ARE AMONG THE
PIONEERS OF UNIVERSAL SERVICE
AND RURAL INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT SERVING HIGH COST
AREAS UP LARGER PROVIDERS HAVE
BEEN HISTORICALLY AND WILLING TO
SERVE IN THE BROADBAND WORLD WE
REMAIN PART OF THE VANGUARD OF
UNIVERSAL SERVICE WORKING EVERY
DAY TO BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
WE CONTINUE SENATE TO SUPPORT
UNIVERSAL SERVICE AND ALL OF ITS
MANIFESTATIONS BECAUSE NETWORKS.
ARE MORE VALUABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHEN MORE PEOPLE
ARE CONNECTED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE COMMISSION AND STAKEHOLDERS
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK
YOU. MR BY SURVIVORS BERNIER
OSCAR WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
GREAT ROBUST DISCUSSION TODAY I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT-
YOU'RE SPOT ON YOU HEARD IT LOUD
AND CLEAR THIS. PROPOSED
DECISION FROM THE PC ON FFA IS
NOT READY SO THERE ARE A COUPLE
ISSUES THAT BEEN HIGHLIGHTED ALL
JUST REITERATED ONCE MORE- THE
AFFORDABLE BROADBAND PLAN NEEDS
TO BE READJUSTED HE SHOULD BE
FOR FOLKS WHO. NEED THAT SERVICE
AND THE PRICE CAP THAT THEY HAVE
FOR TEN YEARS IS UNWORKABLE WHO
IN THEIR RIGHT MIND WOULD WANT
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS I WON'T
REPEAT THAT ISSUE THOUGH YOU HAD
A GREAT DISCUSSION ABOUT IT. SO
I WOULD URGE YOU TO URGE THE
COMMISSION TO HOLD ON ADOPTING
THAT DECISION TOMORROW AND WAIT
TO THE NEXT YEAR AND UNTIL THEY
HAVE A BETTER ROBUST DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT- SECOND MISS BONTA.
WE TALK ABOUT DID YOU EQUITY
THIS IS DID YOU EQUITY- IN THE
WORKS THIS WAS A GREAT
DISCUSSION YOU GUYS HAD TODAY TO
ENSURE THAT FEDERAL- THE- FUNDS
FROM GOVERNMENT THAT ARE USED
FOR. GETTING EVERYONE CONNECTED
ARE SPENT APPROPRIATELY SO WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THAT SO
THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS- IN THE
ROOM ONE TWO OUT TESTIFYING. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE OF. THAT
CONCLUDES THIS INFORMATION
HEARING AND WE ARE ADJOURNED.